for decades the Pearl programming
language has remained important in the
Realms of text processing system
administration and even web development
learn how to use Perl in this complete
course for beginners this course covers
topics ranging from basic syntax to
Advanced topics like object-oriented
programming regular expressions and web
development vaulters has been using
Pearl for years and he will teach you
how to use the language in your own
projects
other and welcome to this lecture in
this course section we will be mostly
working with Pro script files however
before we proceed with looking at
profile structure I just wanted to
quickly show you how you can run Pro
through command line interface
now in order to run Pro through command
line interface you can type Pearl space
minus E for execute then single quotes
or double quotes
I usually tend to use single quotes
because with double quotes you can
interpolate variables and let's use
single quotes for this example and let's
do something like print which is going
to print something to a terminal double
quotes so they don't interfere with or
wrapping single quotes of our Pro code
and say hello
and let's also add a backslash n and the
backslash n is simply a new line so if
you run this by hitting return we're
going to see Hello printed to our
terminal now the alternative how you can
run this is with capital a
and what capital E does is simply
enables some of the pro core features
we're going to look at some of these
features in next lectures but for now
let's explore a very simple and handy
one which is called say and this save
feature is simply adding a new line at
the end of whatever we're printing so if
we run this code again we're going to
see Hello new line followed by another
new line so it's all automatically
adding a new line at the end of whatever
we're printing now if we remove this new
line which we added in the string we're
just going to see a single new line
which is printed after or hello if I
would try to run this with lowercase I'm
going to see an error and that's going
to say that there is something wrong at
line one and if we forgot to declare say
well technically yes we didn't declare
say and the say command wasn't
recognized because we didn't enable
features so Pearl didn't know what say
means and what it is supposed to do you
might be wondering why would this be
useful in general why would I be running
these one-liners well sometimes writing
full script file might be an Overkill
maybe you just want to quickly pour some
input via Pro in this case writing a
script file is probably not the best
solution just to give more elaborate
example and don't worry about the syntax
we will look at it in the future
lectures but let's do something like
Pearl minus a let's do a capital E then
single quotes where we can add our Pearl
code let's say while which is a loop and
an opening and closing parentheses let's
add this diamond operator which is taken
on input
then opening and curly braces for
executing or wild block logic and let's
add something like say UC or uppercase
and let's use this dollar sign
underscore and this dollar sign
underscore is simply the current context
the while loop is receiving and what we
are working on so put to put it simple
it's a while loop which takes an input
from or terminal it runs indefinitely
and it's going to print whatever we're
giving or script and uppercasing it well
it's uppercasing it and then printing it
out so if we run this
we're going to see that nothing happens
and this is because our program now is
waiting for an input but if I do
something like hello lowercase it's
return I'm going to see uppercase hello
printed out and that's what I talked
about basically our program runs tags
and inputs it uppercases the input and
prints it out now of course there can be
hundreds of other more useful scenarios
such as listing files parsing file names
replacing file extensions so on and so
on the scenarios really depends on the
use case but now you know how you can
run Pro through command line interface
if ever you need to I hope you found
this lecture useful and I'll see you at
the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore a basic Pro
script file structure let's begin
here I am currently in my visual studio
code editor and I have opened up an
empty folder
if you are using visual studio code as
well you can open up a folder by going
to file
and choosing open folder
from there you will get a file explorer
pop-up and you can navigate to the
directory in which you want to work in
let's create a new proscript file
you can do this by right-clicking in an
empty space in your Visual Studio code
editor and choosing new file
alternatively as another example you
could create a file using touch command
by opening Visual Studio code terminal
and writing touch followed by the file
name
to open Visual Studio code terminal you
can tap control filter on your Mac
or go to view
terminal
or of course by any other means if you
are not using visual studio code editor
I'm going to create a file through the
editor and name it
Crypt
.pl
the first thing to note is that you end
your pro script files with dot dot PL
extension I will start out by writing
the full basic profile structure and
afterwards we will go into detail of
what each line means
so let's begin hashtag exclamation mark
user bin environment Pearl
you strict
news warnings
it's printed
hello
world
article on one semicolon annual one
okay a lot of things are going on here
for a very basic Pro script file but
don't worry we will go through each line
and explore in detail what it means
before that let's quickly see how we can
run this file
if you go to a terminal
and type Pearl followed by the script
file name which in this case is script
dot El
you're going to see Hello World printed
to your console this line comes from the
print statement we added in our script
file but what about the other lines well
the first line at the top is called she
Bank line and it basically tells your
system how to run this file if the file
is set as executable you can run your
file as executable if you go back to
your console and type dot forward slash
script which is all proscript file name
and press return by default you're going
to see a warning that says permission
denied and that is because currently our
file is not set as executable you can
see this by typing LS for list minus LA
and or file name which is script.pl and
what we see here that or file is
currently set as read and write what
we're missing is the executable tag to
set your file as executable you can
write shmod which is for change mode
plus X and the file name which is our
script.pl
and press return
now if you type LS minus la
or script name which is script.pl you're
going to see this new X tag which means
this file should now be executable if we
try to rerun dot forward slash
script.pl
and note that we did not add Pro before
the script file name
is going to bring hello world
the interesting thing is that if we
remove the shipbank line at the top of
our file
we save it go back to our console and
try to run our script as executable it's
going to complain this is because our
system does not know that this file
should be executed as a pro script and
tries to run it as a batch script
therefore it complains that the content
of this file could not be parsed and
that is the meaning of the shebang line
it basically tells your system how to
run this file if your file is set as
executable and you did not explicitly
specify that it should be run as a pro
script so if we'll add this line back
we save it
we rerun it
and it works again the next two lines
starting with use are called pragmas
there are various pragmas in Pro however
the most standard ones you should always
be using are you strict and use warnings
in a sense these statements enforce you
to write robust and less error prone
code they give you warnings and even
compile time errors when you are trying
to write Pro code that can cause
ambiguous results let's test this by
firstly commenting out the you
statements in Visual Studio code you can
highlight multiple lines of text and tap
command forward slash which is going to
automatically comment your pro code next
let's try to join our hello world string
with a variable in our print statement
and don't worry if this looks confusing
we will look at variable types in our
next lectures along with concatenating
and interpolating variables and strings
however let's just focus on the fact
that this strange variable came out of
nowhere it has no value and we're trying
to randomly append it to our string with
the dot notation what we're doing might
seem wrong and ambiguous and that is
because it is we should not be able to
use something we haven't defined in our
scripts however Pro is not going to
complain unless you tell it to complain
if we try to rerun our script with
explicitly saying Pro
or script name which is script.pl is
going to say hello world and this is
where the strict and warning progress
come into play
it will explicitly tell our proscript
not to allow such ambiguity in our code
if we uncomment warnings
and try to run our code again
we're seeing more output and this output
is main test used only once main
referring to our package which is this
file possibly a typo on a script PL yeah
close enough and it says use initialized
value or scientist in concatenation and
that is true we are using an initialized
value in concatenation with our string
hello world now if we try to recommend
strict
save the file
run it again so Pearl
.pl
is going to say Global symbol test
requires explicit package name did you
forget to declare my test well yes we
did not declare my test variable and
then it says execution of script.pl
aborted due to compilation errors and
this is great now instead of just giving
warnings or script actually bails out
and says no no I don't know what this
variable is I don't want to proceed
compiling this I don't want to run this
please be more explicit with your code
now let's try to Define our variable
before using it so if I say my
test equals
a random value which is a random string
and we save this and I understand if
this might seem confusing at this point
because we haven't looked into variables
and how you define them but a short
summary is that basically we have this
simple scalar which are going to look
into next lectures that we assign a
string which is called random and then
we try to concatenate it with our hello
world now when we have explicitly
defined our variables and we try to
rerun our code
is going to succeed what we're going to
see now is or random
which is the test variable concatenated
with
hello world now finally the print
statement as you probably have guessed
by now simply prints out a text to our
console lastly we are returning a number
this is a standard for proscript but not
necessarily always present it's common
to return a truthy value in your pro
scripts to indicate that the compilation
of your pro script succeeded if you have
a standalone Pro script as we do know
the truthy return value will probably
not be in place however and we will look
into this in use versus require section
if not set the script will throw a
warning when you are using a Perl script
in another Pro script so that's it for
this lecture we looked at the basic
proscript file layout and what is the
meaning of the shebang line along with
this strict and warning progress I hope
you found this video useful and I'll see
you at the next one
other and welcome to this lecture in
this video we're going to explore one of
Pro's data structures scalars let's
begin
so what are scalars well scalars are
single unit of data meaning they can
hold one off undefined number decimal
number string or reference but don't
worry about reference for now you define
a scalar by saying my dollar sign let's
say test equals
one
so we assign a number of value 1 to a
variable scalar named test as mentioned
before you can also assign let's say my
string equals hello
and as well as assigning my decimal
equals 1.22
so one thing to note is that scalar
names are unique so if I try to save my
test equals 1 save this and I try to run
it in my console by Pearl script.pl is
going to say my variable test marks
earlier declaration in same scope and
what this means is basically it's saying
that hmm looks like you did Define a
variable named test and you're trying to
Define a variable which is called test
again you might be doing something wrong
and in this case this is quite true we
are defining my test variable twice and
it does not make a lot of sense on that
note it's worth mentioning that the
variables are also case sensitive so if
I said my
Capital test equals one save this run
the proscript.pl
I'm going to see no warnings and this is
because I have a test variable defined
with a lowercase T and another variable
called test with the same value but
defined with capital T so technically
the variable names are not the same
because one is with a lowercase D and
the other one is with the uppercase D
let's look at some variable operations
we start out with the numbers for
example I'm going to remove string for
now
and I am going to print out a
test
Plus
decimal both console printed out I'm
saying 2.22 so what we did there we
added test
variable value 1 with decimal variable
value 1.22 and what we got in then is
2.22
we can also do the same thing with this
subtraction so if I say test minus
decimal I go back to the console I rerun
the script file what I'm going to say is
minus 0.22 and that makes sense because
1 minus 1.182 equals minus 0.22 you can
also do multiplication which is 1 times
0.122 rerun this and it's the same as
1.22 and you can do division as well so
this which is 1 divided by 1.22 go to
console you know rerun the Pearl script
file you're going to see a very
ambiguous number but let's just assume
this is right probably it's going to
make more sense if we say
this equals 20 and we divided by 5 which
would give us 4 and yes here we go we
see number four printed out to our
console now let's look at the strings
let's reintroduce our variable named
string equals hello there are a couple
of things you can do with the strings
for example so if I have a string
variable so variable named string and
number two equals
hello to
I can print out
string
and concatenate it with this dot
notation with string 2. there it is we
run our Pro script file I'm going to see
Hello concatenated with hello two so
another thing I can do with strings is I
can interpolate them
for example I could convert string 2
with double quotation marks and say
hello to
space
string variable save this and I'm going
to replace the print statement with only
string 2.
save this go to the console run
proscript.pl
and I'm going to say hello to Value
which comes from here
space
and the value of string you can also use
special variables in your strings such
as a break line you might have noticed
that in our console usually when we run
our script we're going to end up with
the terminal input at the end of what we
printed it's not quite great so what we
probably want to introduce is a new line
and how you can add a new line is by
adding backslash n we save this we rerun
our script and what you're going to see
now this is the value we printed out
followed by new line so my terminal
input is on the next line one thing to
note this is only usable when you're
using double quotes this will not work
for single quotes what I mean is if I
would say backslash n in my variable
string and I would try to print this out
what I'm actually going to see is the
hello to Value which we see here and the
variable hello which holds hello
backslash n which is just a string so
you cannot use use these special
variables in strings which have single
quotation marks you can also use special
variables such as backslash T which
stands for tab we rerun or Pro script
file and what we're going to see is
there is a slight extra break here but
it's not that quite visible so if we add
let's say two more
backslashes
C and rerun the file yes this is much
more visible we can see that we have
inserted tabs here so let's try to
concatenate a number with a string so
I'm going to remove the string too and
again say my scalar and let's call it a
number just a scalar name equals one and
we try to print out string
detonated with variable number let's
also add that break line here which is
backslash n
and let's run this so Pro
op.pl and what we're going to see here
is the hello value which is in the
string because we will have the
backslash n here
and followed by number one
so when you're trying to concatenate a
string with a number Pro is going to be
smart enough to understand that what you
actually want to do you want to convert
the number to string and concatenate
that together but what happens if we try
to let's say sum variable number and
variable string let's do that let's
replace string documentation for which
is concatenation with Plus
and let's still leave the dot by slash n
for the new line and let's save that
let's go back to the console rerun it
and it's going to say argument hello
isn't numeric in addition so this means
that Pro is smart enough to figure out
that you're trying to use a number which
is in variable number and you're trying
to add it to a variable called string
which holds a string and it doesn't seem
quite right because you are trying to
sum up a string with a number one final
thing to add is for example if you
wanted to print a double quoted string
such as hello
and use a variable
let's say number
but you don't really want to print out
the value of this variable but you
literally want to say hello dollar sign
number
so you can do this by backslash before
the variable sigil and it's going to
escape your variable in the double
quotes
let's save this go back to the console
set Purl script.pl and here we go we say
hello dollar sign number so this
variable number one wasn't interpreted
inside the double quoted string so
hopefully it's a lot clearer what is a
scalar in Pearl how you create and
assign values to scalars including doing
some basic operations such as adding
numeric values and concatenating strings
I hope you found this video useful and
I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture
before we move towards exploring other
data types in Pro I would like to
introduce you to an alternative and much
better way to debug your pro code
instead of using print statements this
alternative is using a module called
data dumper and how you can use it is by
saying use
data colon colon dumper semicolon to
note you do not need to explicitly
install this module as long as you're
using pro version 5.36 or above meaning
this module is part of pro default core
modules and to be more precise the data
dumper module should be available from
pro version 5.1a later in this section
we will explore in more detail how to
install and use modules along with how
to use statement Works behind the scenes
however for now the key takeaway is that
when we write this use data dumper we
get access to a powerful debugging
method called dumper and how we can
invoke this is by saying
print
dumper
opening bracket and closing bracket and
any good submit column so everything
which we put in between the brackets is
going to get debugged in our terminal so
basically this method AKA dumper
function takes a list of arguments and
will print out detailed information
about the given data let's try it out by
printing some data about scalar
variables I'm going to introduce a
scalar a variable called a which is
going to hold a string and it's going to
say hello anyway semicolon and I'm also
going to introduce a variable called B
which is going to hold a decimal let's
say
22.32 and then that and now I'm going to
add these variables in between the
dumper function so lower sign a comma
dollar sign B save this go to the
console and write referral
crypt.pl
and what I'm going to see is this var1
currently holds hello and variable 2
holds
22.32 and what this refers to is that
variable 1 War 1 is the position of the
variable being debugged in this case the
var1 refers to Plus on a which holds a
value of a string which says hello now
the vowel to at position 2
holds
a value of 22.32 which we can see here
you might be thinking well this does not
differ much from what we saw in our
previous lectures using print and you
are right at the current time it does
not differ much and that is because
we're using basic date types such as
strings and numbers however the real
power of this debugging module will
become much more apparent the more we
use it in our future lectures with more
complicated data structures like arrays
hashes and references
so this is it for this lecture we looked
at how we can use the data dumper
debugging module I hope you found this
video useful and I'll see you at the
next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we're going to explore the
second Pro Data type array
so what is an array array is a data type
that holds order list of values these
values Can Be Strings numbers decimals
and references but as before don't worry
about the references at this point
quick note list and array are often used
as if they are the same but the list is
the data you assign to array and array
is the actual variable
or you can create an array is by saying
my
at symbol
test
equals parentheses
and semicolon let's try to debug it now
as we did before so let's say print
dumper and in between there we're going
to add our test
we're going to end it with semicolon go
back to our console save
proop.pl and we're going to get nothing
and this is normal because we haven't
added anything into our array yet so
let's do that next let's introduce
couple of values such as
a number let's say 22 a string which is
going to say hello and a decimal let's
say 1.22 let's save it up let's go back
to our console let's rerun the
proscript.pl and what we're going to see
now is that the variable remembered on
the left hand side these are positions
one two three and the values being 22
hello
1.22 so what happened here since this is
a list we got all the elements printed
other positions as we have defined in
our list sequence so variable one is 22
variable 2 is hello and variable 3 is
1.182 such as we can see here
no alternative way if you're using with
only strings and single words what you
can do is you can use this keyword
called q w which is for fault board and
followed by forward slashes and say one
two three
now if you debug that you're going to
see one two three and this is quite a
handy shortcut instead of using
parentheses quoting your strings if you
only need strings in your list and those
strings are not separated by spaces such
as one two three and then you want to
add
a single string which is my four
with your end up with is actually
five items in the list so one two three
my being a separate item because it's
separated by space And Then followed by
four now in order to access all items in
a list and I'm going to remove this my
keyword so we have one two three you can
use dollar sign followed by your list
name which is going to be test
square bracket and the position of an
element in your list now take note here
that all the positions of items in the
array starts at zero meaning
the string 1 is going to be at position
zero string two is going to be at index
position 1.
3 at index position two and four at
index position three
it might seem confusing but basically
just think about it how many items you
have in your list just add minus one and
that's how you can access it so for
example if I wanted to access let's say
string of three I can do
course and test square brackets and
index position of two
save this go to the console I print it
out which is Purl trip.pl and here we go
we're going to see variable equals three
because you're accessing the index
position two which is zero
one two it holds a string of three you
can also override items in your list by
using the same notation of index
so let's say I'm going to remove this
I'm going to still print out the test
and I'm going to say test
and let's say I want to override the
item at position 3 which should be our
string four
and I want to say that this is now
override
save this go to our console print it out
and what I'm going to see now is one two
three and override because we override
the variable which is at position index
3 meaning 4 with a new string override
now the interesting thing is that let's
say I wanted to add an item at position
10. I'm going to say test position 10 is
override now I'm going to print out the
list and what I'm gonna see is now that
we have one two three four represented
by items here
and then we have these undefined values
that we looked at in the previous
lecture which means it has no value at
these positions and then the 11th item
which is -1
index and
is override which we just said now
now what if I wanted to access this last
item in the list so instead of needing
to know how many items and the index
positions I have in the list what I can
do I can say
-1
and actually let's say that I wanted to
not introduce a new item at a position
-1 but I'm going to say test and I want
access minus one
which should be the item 4 at the end of
the list if I save this print this out
and here we go I see variable
position one
is a value of 4. the same goes if I
wanted to access
-3
is going to be one
two three which should be value of two
let's set this up and I debug this and I
see that the value printed out is two a
little bit confusing because if we want
to access items at the end of array we
actually need to start at position
-1 if we want to access items from the
first position
it starts at zero it's just something to
keep in mind now another thing you might
want to know is how many items we have
in the list and the way how you can do
this is by saying my let's say Define a
variable size equals a test
now if we print out the test go to our
console we're going to see that oops we
have to do we actually have a variable
defined the size apologies we save this
we run the pro script again and we're
gonna see that it's four and that's
right because we have one two three four
items in our array which is called test
now here what happens is that since
we're trying to assign a list to a
scalar we're actually employing a scalar
context right because a scalar can hold
a single unit of data it cannot hold a
list so what it's going to do is going
to take the list size and assign the
number of items to this size variable so
another thing you might want to know you
want to know what is the last index in
our array the way how you can do this is
by saying last let's say let's Define a
variable of last index equals dollar
sign hashtag is going to be the name of
our list which is test and now if we
print out last
index
we go to the terminal parallel script.pl
we're going to see three and that is
correct because the index is 3 we have
four items as we debugged before but the
last index is three because we start at
zero so zero one two three now let's
look at some very useful methods how we
can quickly populate or raise using
sequential numbers or letters let's say
I want to populate my list with numbers
from 11 to 30. you can go one two three
four and well I mean that's actually 11
12 13 and so on but there is a shortcut
and a lot much quicker way you can say
11.
dot dots 30. now we save this and what
we actually want to print out is
this list we override that go to console
print it and what we're going to see is
that our array get automatically
populated with numbers from 11 till 30.
so all the way down from here at
position one up to position 20. you can
do the same thing with letters let's say
I wanted to populate the array with
letters from A one two
to see
I go to the terminal I print this and
here we go
ABCD so on and up to Z
and you can of course also do like age
and just go to n
your God console print this so g h i j k
l m n so let's say I only wanted to
access specific elements in my list
that contains numbers one two three four
I can do this by saying the variable
name which is a rename test and I can
give index positions so if I wanted to
access only the elements 3 and 4 again
go 0 1
two three so if I say two dot dot three
save this say pearl trip.pl I'm going to
see three and four
because index position 2 is 0 1 2 and
index position 3 is 4. there are four
commonly used methods when working with
arrays let's explore them in more detail
let's keep our list in a place and let's
say I just want to debug the list itself
and I'm going to write the mods the
methods which are commonly used which
are push
pop shift and unshift
so what the push does it adds an element
at the end of the array for example if I
say push
you provide the rename which is test and
let's say I want to add number 20. save
this
and I print out my items and I see one
two three four and or new item which is
20. now pop removes an element from the
end of the array so if I say pop
array name which is test and save this
and a reprint I'm going to see one two
three four which is just original list
now shift is going to remove the first
item from the list so if I say shift
ADD test
save this
rerun and I see two three four because
or item one got removed now unshift is
going to do the opposite of shift which
you can imagine is it's adding an
element at the beginning of the list so
on shift
let's say at test
save this and reprint we're going to say
20 2 3 4. so because we push an item on
the list
we removed an item from the end of the
list we shifted an item from beginning
of list which was one and then we added
an item at beginning of the list which
is 20. so another useful thing you can
do with your list is sort them
and by default pro has this sort method
but it works with strings by default so
let's look at example of sorting strings
using sort method
so I say h
o p m l a b c
space here apologies looks like I'm
missing the space so to sort this list
you want to say ADD test you want to
replace this list with the sorted value
which is sort
and you simply provide a list because as
I mentioned the sort method by default
works on strings
so if you try to sort this test list we
should get back the expected results
I'll save this go to our console say
pearl.pl going to be ABCD hlmop that
looks alright because we had a hopm and
so on and so on and this does look like
a sorted list of letters now what if we
want to sort numeric list so let's
remove this let's introduce
4 2 10 22 and maybe 30.
if I try to say test sort test
and print this out
so something does happen it says 10 2 22
34 but it does not look quite what we
would expect and this is because it's
actually sorting these numbers Based On
A String context what we want is to
explicitly Define a function after the
sort method
which we're going to say a doing the
first element what we receive in this
method
this comparison symbol which is also
referred to as spaceship symbol and
value B which is the next item we're
going to iterate over I save this go
back to the console and add print cell
again
and I see 2 4 10 22 30. you can also
reverse this by saying B
n a save this reprint and it's going to
be 30 22 10 and so on in the next
lectures you're also going to explore
additional methods as join split grip
and map in Pearl built-in function
section
so these are definitely by any means the
only functions we have to work on lists
so this is it for this lecture we looked
at what are arrays and pro how you
create and fetch values in arrays and we
also looked at basic methods to interact
with the race and pro I hope you found
this video useful and I'll see you at
the next lecture
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we're going to explore the
final Pro Data type which is called the
hash so what is a hash a hash is simply
a set of key value pairs you store and
access your values in a hash using keys
the values in the hash Can Be Strings
numbers or references but as I have said
you don't need to worry about references
at this point hashes are an excellent
solution if you need a fast lookup of
values if you know the key think of it
as a phone book but faster of course so
basically you have a person's name and
you would like to look up their phone
number
you can have thousands of entries in
hash and quickly look it up using a key
let's look at example to make this
clearer to declare a hash you can say my
presenter sign let's call it a map
equals
parentheses now let's try to debug it so
print
bumper
and or hash save it we go to console
roll script.pl you're going to see
nothing so as before since we don't have
any values we are not seeing anything in
our console let's change that let's say
I wanted to add a key which is a that's
going to point to a number let's say 20
a key B which is going to point to a
string which is hello
and PC which is going to point to 11.22
if I save this go back to the console
and I rerun the pro script what I'm
going to see is actual list values so
positions being one two three four five
six a 20 C 11 22 and B hello
and this is because technically hash is
a a list that has elements following
order of key
comma value
now the thing to note is that this list
is never going to have the same order
as you can see already here we have item
a with value 20 as we have defined in
our hash however the next value is C
1122 which should be B hello
and it's not the case because the order
is never going to be preserved in a hash
so if I rerun this again I'm going to
see C 11 22 a20 and if I rerun
you can see as before the order changes
all the time if you want to access a
specific key in our hash it's very
similar to array so we're going to use
dollar sign the name of our hash which
is map
but instead of using square brackets
we're going to use curly brackets
go like this and then we're going to
give our key which in this case can be
let's say C we save this we rerun and we
see
now what we debug the variable one
which holds the value of 11.22 if you
want to set a new value we can do the
same thing very similar to arrays but
we're going to use dollar map instead of
square brackets we're going to use curly
brackets and instead of the position of
our element we want to add we're going
to say we want to add a new key which is
ABCD
equals new now if we print out the D key
we're going to say new one important
thing about hashes is that the keys are
unique meaning you cannot have more than
one key with the same name in your hash
so what I mean by that is that if I
remove what I debug before replace it
with our hash set this and let's say I
wanted to add C equals
2 and C equals let's say a string new
I save this and I debug my hash and what
I'm going to see is that c
all the value of new and this is
important because we have three key
value pairs in our hash but what is
preserved is the latter value in the
hash
so all the keys which come before the
final key with the same name is going to
be overridden meaning this is original
key which was already done by C with
value 2 and then overridden Again by c
new on the same topic it's worth
mentioning the keys are unique so what
you could have you can have a Capital C
which points to a value U
if we save this we print out our evalu
list we're going to say Capital C equals
new
and alongside that we're going to see
our lowercase c
11.22 as for the key names you can have
letters or numbers or underscores in
your key names however once you want to
start introducing special characters
such as percentage sign or space what
you need to do you actually have to wrap
your key name with a quote
so if we save this
and we debug our hash we're going to see
or key of one underscore percentage sign
space or the value of new
and if we remove these quotes
and save this
well you might imagine this probably
going to be invalid syntax and that is
true because we see misplaced underscore
syntax error at percentage side and it
gets very confusing something is very
very wrong another useful thing to know
is that you can merge two hashes
together
let's say I have my map with some values
and let's remove this one which is
breaking your script we save this and
let's say my map 2 equals
new hash and I'm going to say I have
keys low which points to number one and
I'm going to add percentage sign and map
save this and I'm gonna debug map 2.
so what we're going to have here is our
original keys pointing to our values
plus the hello one which is going to
point to hello
one this is how you can merge multiple
hashes together you can even explicitly
override the values in a hash saying I
want the C to be new
a debug
the C holds the value of Nu now so what
happened here we had original hash
we merged it into the second hash
we spread the values so to say and then
we override the value of C which is
11.22 with a new value which is string
new so similar as with the Rays you can
also access slices of hashes for example
let's remove the second array and let's
print out the first array let's save it
and how you access specific slices of a
hash is by using at symbol before your
hash name curly brackets
and then the name of the keys for
example if I wanted to access A and C I
would say a comma C save this and if I
print out sorry
let's use the quotation marks and if I
print this out I'm gonna see value of 20
and a value of 1122 because I'm
accessing y sub a with value 20 and
slice of C of value 11 22. now let's
explore some very useful methods that's
going to help you to work with hashes
so one of these methods is called keys
and as you can imagine it does exactly
that it Returns the keys of the hash now
let's say I want to introduce a new
array Which is my array
and I'm going to say keys
for Center sign map which is our hash
name save this and what I'm going to
debug is the actual array named array
and we go to our console we print this
out and we see BAC and because the keys
method returns all the keys of a hash
and the hash keys are never sorted
they're always changing we're going to
get back random order of the keys so we
start to do BAC now it's ACB and so on
and so on the keys method is also very
useful if you want to get the size of
the hash so my size equals ease and the
name of the hash now very similar what
we saw with array is that here we have
scalar context and we say I want to see
how many keys there are in the map hash
so we're going to get back all the keys
in this map as we saw before but we are
imposing a scalar context so this
becomes a list
where the scalar context is the imposed
so what we should get back now is the
amount of keys aka the size of the hash
which is three so another thing is that
for example if you want to see if a key
exists in a hash but you want to avoid
checking condition where it could be
false for example ABCD equals on Def
you can use a keyword called exists and
how we can check if the key exists is
you can use a ternary expression and
don't worry about this now we will look
into ternary expression later on but
basically we can check the existence of
the value by saying exists is just a
scalar name equals
exists this is the function where we say
or map hash
since we try to access a value we use
dollar notation
we're going to check for key which is
called d
and the ternary statement goes with
question mark which says is this first
expression true if this is true then we
say yes and then you use colon which is
if this expression is not true which is
going to score the string of no
now we can print out the exists
save this go to the console print it out
and it says yes it does exist
if you wouldn't use this keyword
and we remove the exists
we print it out it's going to say no
because well technically our key does
exist in or hash however since we are
checking on a true thick context and in
Pro on the find is not a truthy truthy
value would be one or a string or a
positive number but in this case we're
using undef which is not true T value
and that's what exist keyword is quite
useful because it says okay well do we
have the key we don't care about the
value but do we have it in our hash and
in this case yes we do have it if we say
do we have a key of Z save this print it
out no we don't have key of Z and the
final useful method word mentioning is
delete I could delete items from my hash
and how I can delete items from my hash
is I'm going to remove this statement
and I'm going to print out my hash
this I can call delete
as before we use dollar notation to
access a single element in our hash so
I'm going to say dollar sign map
and I can say delete C
let's add this
rerun the script
and as you see there's no more C here so
we have d b and a I can repeat this line
by saying also remove a and also remove
the
before I reprint this
here we go we only have B left in our
hash this is it for this video we looked
at what our hashes in Pearl or you can
create and access values in a hash and
we also explore basic operations on the
hash structure I hope you found this
video useful and I'll see you at the
next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we're going to explore what
our references I said multiple times in
previous lectures that you should not
worry about references however that has
changed we have come to the point where
we do have to worry about references but
don't feel intimidated the more you work
with references the more it becomes
clearer what they are how they work and
how extremely powerful they are so what
is a reference well reference is
basically a location in memory which
points to another data structure such as
array hash or scalar reference allows
you to construct nested date structures
such as hashes where Keys pointerested
reference like array or hash reference
or arrays the contain reference to Hash
or array reference at set position I
understand if this also is confusing but
don't worry just think of it that
previously when we were merging arrays
and hashes we could not be able to point
a key to a hash because or hash gets
automatically merged in or so to say
normal data structure which is array or
hash with references you can actually
Nest the hash structure or array
structure which can be very very useful
in a lot of scenarios you might have
also heard of a term passing by value or
passing by reference when you pass data
in your code using value you're
duplicating the data in memory and
allocating new memory space for your
values when you pass by reference you're
actually passing the location of data
structure in memory instead of copying
the data passing by reference can be
extremely useful if you want to work
with the same data reference in your
code instead of constantly copying your
data all over let's look at some
examples what I have in front of me is a
simple hash which is named hash and it
holds a key A and B which points to
values 1 and 2 respectively I also have
array which is defined with with this
quote forward syntax and hold string 1
string two and I have a scalar which
simply holds a number 32 2. now to get
references to these values we can use
the special syntax which is using a
backslash before your data structure
what I mean is if I try to do print I
can say backslash hash save this up for
the console Runway proscript.pl and I'm
going to see this strange value and
basically this is a reference in memory
it says that water printing out here is
a reference in memory instead of
actually printing out the hash you could
try to print out a hash as it is
like this
we're going to see b 2 a 1 which is
basically a list printed out B being the
key and two being a value an a a key and
one a value the same would be with array
right so if we say array if we print out
array we're just going to print out the
values that are string 1 string two now
if we add a backslash before the array
we're actually going to see this syntax
is going to say hey what you're working
with here is array references and this
is the points in the memory for this
reference and this point in the memory
is not going to change so if we say for
example print many array references
we're going to see that
oh maybe let's add a new line character
so it's better formatting so what I'm
doing now on Mac is I'm pressing option
command and down arrow to select
multiple lines space double quotes
because we want to use special
characters and N Save this go to the
console print it out and you're going to
see that all of these values are
actually the same it says it's a hash
ref and this is the point in a memory we
printed it out many times but it never
changed because this array has been
already allocated in the memory and all
of these references are pointing to the
same allocation of the data structure
now let's look at some example where we
are assigning a reference to a scalar
then we're trying to modify that
reference let's do this let's create my
ref1 equals backslash let's choose array
and do my ref2 and backslash array and
let's do this let's try to push
something on this reference one because
well it should be a hash a riff one and
let's say string new just for new string
we go to console and we try to run this
it's going to say oh you're trying to
push a something on a scalar which is
forbidden and the thing is that when
you're trying to manipulate references
you always have to de-reference your
reference before working with them so
basically what it means you have to get
your Regional data structure back in
order to push or pop or access an
element and so on so referencing was
using backslash before or data structure
e-referencing is well you can actually
do it many ways one of my preferred ways
is I use Arrow syntax as such and then I
say that this is array and you use this
asterisks you save it and you try to run
it and it didn't complain because we are
de-referencing this and trying to push a
new string which is fine because we can
use push method on array now let's also
do this let's try to print out what we
are actually getting back in Array so
print dumper oh
dumper and let's print out the array
let's save this go to the console run
this again and here we go we see string
1 and string two and we also see our new
value so as you can see we pushed onto a
reference that we dereference so we can
you know push things on it and we added
a new value and now we have three values
on the array we could do the same thing
for reference two right we could try to
push let's say
new too
go back to console print this out and
here we go so we have our two original
values in our array which were defined
here then we have references reference
one reference to
apologies which points to the same
data structure in a memory so basically
reference 1 and reference 2 holds the
same pointer in memory that says hey
this is this array and then we are using
this reference to say hey add this value
to
this structure in memory and the same
for reference too it's exactly the same
pointer as reference one so we're just
adding a value Nu 2 to or array so as
you can see all scalars that point to
that reference when edited will affect
the original data structure now we
looked at how we can get a reference
from existing data structure now let's
see what happens if we are debugging
these values with data dumper using
references so here I have my array again
I backslash it as we did before to get a
reference in memory and we print it out
and you're going to see that instead of
value 1 and value 2 being printed out
with position War 1 War 2 we're actually
printing out a position bar one which
holds this square brackets having two
elements inside of it which is string
one string two so this indicates that we
are working with array reference the
same thing if we did with hash reference
press enter sign hash say this what
we're going to see now instead of list
items of e being let's say what one
pointing to Bar 2 which is the value
you're going to see the hash reference
is included in curly brackets A1 and B2
being our keys and values now the same
thing goes for the scalars so you can
say scalar
and print it out and instead of seeing
just a value 32 we're actually seeing
this backslash which indicates we are
working with array reference now it's
worth knowing that you can construct
reference the same way how you can
construct a hash or array and the way
you do it is using the syntax as it was
printed out in data dumper
so I'm going to get rid of these values
I'm going to say my hashref
as we saw before we need to use early
brackets
and let's say add a key hello one
enrolled
with value 2. if we print this out
you're going to see this is a hash
reference because we're using these
curly braces instead of just parentheses
so we're working with hash references
the same goes with arrays so let's say I
want to construct a array ref
and what we saw before being printed out
by data dumper was these square brackets
so does the same thing to construct
array reference we can say number one
two three
save this and print out the array ref
look at the console and here we go so
our square brackets one two three and
closing square brackets now how can you
access items in your references I'm
going to go back and introduce the
ashref with values of a well key
pointing to Value 1 and B pointing to
Value 2. set this up what if I want to
access let's say in hash reference only
the key a it's very similar as you would
work with hashes in hashes you would say
Ash
ref and then you use the curly braces to
access element a however what you need
to do when you're working with
references you always need to
de-reference them and one of the way how
you can develop reference is by using
this arrow notation so you can access
key a save this print it out and here we
go we can see that this is number one if
we wouldn't use the real syntax if I get
rid of this save it try to rerun the
script it's going to say hey looks like
you're not using the referencing syntax
and you're accessing a hash somewhere
but I don't see this being defined did
you forget to Define hashref well
technically no he didn't forget to
Define it it's just we didn't want to
access a hash we wanted to access a hash
reference right so this is where we need
to de-reference using this arrow
notation the same goes for if I want to
access an element with array within
array so I would say array ref error
syntax square brackets as we saw before
with the Rays and then v-axis by index
so if I wanted to access item with value
2 which is at the index position 0 1 I
would type 1 here and I print this out
and I see value of 2 because the same as
with arrays array reference items are
indexed starting at position zero so
zero one two so if you're accessing
index one that means we're getting this
element so what if you wanted to
dereference your whole hash you can do
this in many ways you could say
ashref
arrow notation presenter sign Asterix
instead this we go to our console print
it out and here we go we sell that same
pattern of elements being key value
printed out it's exactly the same for
array ref however you would replace
percentage sign with ADD symbol save
this and go to the console print it out
and items one two three but remember you
write a reference or get a reference in
memory for data structures such as array
hash or scalar by using backslash but if
you want to convert back from array
reference into the data structure you
would use dereferencing not referencing
syntax alternative D referencing syntax
would be using the symbol before dollar
sign save this we rerun it and we see
one two three and yet another way how
you can be reference is you can use at
or what is the original data type curly
brackets and ending curly brackets if we
run this it works
now I mentioned previously there is a
thing about references specifically hash
references and array references that you
can create in essay structures so let's
explore that let's say I have a key a
pointing to one big two and what if I
want a key C that points to a another
hash reference or a hash structure so
let's say it's possible with hash
references so basically what you're
doing here is you're pointing to
reference in memory right so you're not
kind of merging your structure in you
can say a b is pointing to numbers and C
is pointing to reference so you can say
nu equals 1 and New 2 equals number two
and if we try to print out the hash
reference now
hash ref save this print it out it's
going to say here are my original values
and here's the new C value we added it's
nested and we can also introduce more
nested values such as deeply
and point to let's say array reference
with values
three four and five I save this I print
out my hash and here we go for the key
is now pointing to Hash reference and as
I mentioned before this can be extremely
useful when you need to store
information in object pattern where keys
are pointing to various types of data or
information about the object you're
working with the question is how for
example we could access the value of C
so the Key C in that hash reference the
value of key nu2 so what you could do is
the same thing as we looked at the
dereferencing is you use Arrow syntax
you say Key C
and then you keep the referencing with
arrow syntax saying my
new key too if I print the cell we have
the value of 2 which is under the key
new two the same thing if I want to go
deeper and say I actually want to access
the deeply key which holds array ref so
since we know it's array ref what we
need to do is we use the same arrow
notation and we access the value by
index let's say 2 which is going to be 0
2 meaning it should be value of 5. we
save that we run it oh and it looks like
we have syntax error so we are accessing
our hashref EC which is here and then we
say there should be a deeply e on the
new 2 which is actually pointing to
value of 2. what we need to do we
actually need to access the deeply on
the C structure so if we change that we
rerun it and here we go the value of
five and the same goes for arrays so if
we wanted to add nested date structure
such as is my array ref and I'm gonna
say first of all is just going to be one
the second one can be a hash f
and we're going to use this quote word
syntax which we're going to spread in
some strings into the second element
which is a
being B and C the third element can be a
hashrev which says a with value 1 B can
be a nested hash ref which has a key C
that points to a hash f
that let's say has an element of hash F
again with a key a pointing to a new
hash F and so on and so on and so on but
you get it the point being is that when
you're working with hashgraphs you can
Nest the date structures as much as you
want if I try to print out this
structure which is array ref and I save
this
here we go we have first items
index position one is value one then it
has a hash drive with these three
strings ABC and then we have this nested
structure which is a holding a hash ref
value and if we try to access this and
let's add a value for example like find
me so it's going to hold two strings one
and me so let's look into how we can
access these structures it's going to
start with dereferencing 0 1 2 so it
should be at index position two we move
forward we want to access a key which is
B
so we type EP
we then want to move deeper access the
Key C and the key C is actually pointing
to a array ref which we can see here and
the first element is a chef so we access
the first element and we know this is a
hash F and then we dereference that and
we that one has a key a and if we save
this and print out and here we go it's
going to say find me now some of the
very useful methods you can use when
you're working with these references is
called ref so let me just clear this up
a bit and let's leave the hash F only
you can use this function called ref
it takes a value in between it and you
can add hash ref
and what's going to tell you is that
you're currently working with a hashref
right so ref tells you if the data
structure you're working with easy
reference in this case yes this is a
hash ref you could be passing in a raref
save this and this is anonymous array
ref we are not assigning assigning it to
a scalar but that's fine you can have
Anonymous references not belonging to
any scaler if you do this it's going to
say this is a raref the same of course
goes for scalar so you can use the same
methods on references as you would use
on your hashes or arrays however you
always need to de-reference your
structure what I mean by that is for
example if you wanted to say keys on
your hashgraph save this but the console
is going to say you're starting to use
keys on scalar and that's forbidden and
you can easily avoid that by just saying
that we want to dereference it by some
of the ways we looked at before for
example array notation
percentage sign and star so we save this
and we run it and here we go we see Keys
BAC the exactly same thing would be for
if you wanted to call the values you
also need to reference this to delete
things such as hash
ref
equal let's say we're going to remove
the key and we print out just a hash ref
here it is you have the key C and only
key a so B was deleted the same would be
for example if an element exists but
remember you also need to dereference it
with this Arrow annotation so this is it
for this lecture we looked at what our
references how you access and interact
with references and why they are
extremely useful
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will learn what are
subroutines in Pearl and how we can use
them and we'll also look into Pro
subroutine signatures also known as
passing named subroutine arguments let's
begin first of all a subroutine is
exactly the same thing as a function
it's a group of statements encapsulated
in a single function to perform a
specific task subroutines AKA functions
are extremely useful in any programming
language to encapsulate and reuse logic
in your code typically each subroutine
is written so that it accomplishes a
very specific task let's look at how we
can use subroutines to define a
subroutine you can use this keyword
called sub followed by space and then
your function AKA subroutine name I'm
going to call my function test and the
logic that should be executed by the
subroutine is in these curly brackets we
have written our first function if I go
to that console and try to run my script
which is hoop which is Pearl screen PL
you can see nothing and this is because
well we have defined our subroutine and
it is a valid context but there are two
issues first of all it doesn't do
anything let's change that let's say I
wanted to print
Hello exclamation mark and backslash n
for new line save this we have
encapsulated the logic but we're not
calling it because the subroutine is not
going to be invoked by default if you
want invoke a subroutine you can say
test which is also routine name followed
by parentheses and then semicolon now if
we do this we run our script we're going
to see hello now this is all great and
all but what if we wanted to accept some
parameters and let's say that parameter
was a name and we want to say hello
someone the way how you can pass in
arguments is by using a list context
between these parentheses where you have
defined your function name so let's say
I want to say John so that's my first
argument but how can we get this
argument into our function itself all
the arguments in function is held in
this special variable we haven't seen
this before but basically think of it as
just an array so all the arguments being
passed into your subroutine is going to
be held into this magical array item at
index position 0 is going to be John
this array is going to hold the string
at position one technically we should be
able to say my name equals
this is just normal array but with this
special notation how we can access items
in Array is we either use the dollar
sign syntax followed by square brackets
index position 0 so this oh we actually
wanna now interpolate the name we save
this and go back to the console and
rerun it and here we see hello John it
might be clear if we say that this is my
args
and I just copy all the values there so
it's nothing really special about this
array apart from that it holds the
values passed into the function so here
we would be just copying these arguments
and then we could say
instead of this underscore we're just
saying orgs right because we learned
about it before you access specific
elements in your array using dollar sign
notation followed by square brackets we
save this we run it
it works as before and just quickly show
another alternative is that we could
have used a shift function right we
could shift off items from or
array which is this special one holding
all the elements and when we call shift
we get the first item in the list and it
should be the name and here we go hello
John this is also where references
become very apparently useful because if
we wanted to pass a array or a hash we
wouldn't be able to pass the content as
a whole right because what would end up
happening is that all the items from
array and a hash would be spread into
this special array we wouldn't be able
to pass the whole structure Let Me Show
an example so let's say I have my array
that holds both words just that three
strings which is a B and C
now how can I get a full structure
without simply spreading the array
elements into this special function
argument placeholder let's see what
happens first we just try to pass an
array I'm going to remove this and I'm
going to say now I want to print the
dumper and I'm going to print all the
arguments on this special array and here
I'm passing in
array I save this up and here we go so
basically argument one was a argument B
was it position two an argument T was
you know at position three you might
want that but most likely you didn't
maybe you just wanted to pass in the
whole data structure and this is where
you can use references so as we looked
at before you can use backslash to get a
reference of your array and now if we
debug this special argument placeholder
we're going to see that we passed in
oops need to save my file as thin a
reference so we didn't copy all the
values into the special array we
actually just said this is a reference
in memory to this array now what we
could do for example in our function we
could move the print statement out
and say I want to print out my array
but I want to do something in this
function and let's say I wanted to push
something on this array inside the
function and then let's see how already
changes first of all I want to get my
array ref which I passed in into the
function and I can do this by shifting
off the first argument of array so I'm
going to say my ARG equals shift special
array so the argument should be the
array reference I can use push
ARG and it de-reference it and say this
is a array reference and I want to say
from function
so I'm going to push a new string on
this array inside my function after
running it and now I say print
and here we go now I have four elements
on my array and we push this from
function string here when we passed in
Array reference let's quickly look at
variable scope so we know that if we for
example say my scalar equals hello
and we would try to reuse this myscaler
and Define a value of something else it
would complain that hey looks like you
have another
scalar defined with the same name this
does not count when you're using
functions because in functions you are
in a different scope so this curly
bracket and this curly bracket indicates
that this is scope of the function for
example let's get rid of the this code
and just say hello Mission Mark and this
and we're gonna color function but we
have no more array and we don't print
anything if I got this it looks all good
but if I gonna say my scalar equals a
save this go to the console print it out
don't complain my variable scalar masks
earlier decoration same scope now if I
move this scalar into here
and rerun the function it's not going to
complain because well myscaler is
defined inside the test function and the
scalar bullet is defined into our main
file so I try to use
the scalar you might be wondering if
it's going to use the scalar which is
defined outside the function or it's
going to use the scalar which is defined
inside the function and let's see if I
run this
and you might have guessed it right it
actually used the scalar inside the
function because that's the local scope
scalar and it wouldn't make sense if he
had a variable with the same name which
is outside a function we're redefining
it and we try to print something and
it's re-referencing the value of scalar
which is outside the function another
thing to note is that you can Define
multiple subroutines so I can say this
too
and I can say print hello from test 2.
now the thing is that you can call
subroutines from another subroutine so
let's replace this with hello from test
save it up also to note the order of how
you define subroutines do not matter for
example if you had a scalar with a value
allow and you try to print that before
the definition of scalar that will
complain it's not the case with silver
things these are actually initialized at
compile time so you can do
test so you call the test subroutine
from Test 2 which is defined before test
and let's replace it with this 2 and we
run our code and here we go we see hello
from test and hello from test two
because we are calling test function
which is defined here inside the test
tube function which is called here now a
good thing to note is that I would
advise you to always be explicit when
you are returning data in your function
it's good to Define when you want to
return void contacts through return on
dev or you actually want to return some
value or calculated value and pearl
functions are always going to return the
last value you worked with so you don't
need specifically have return statement
for example if I say print dumper and
here I'm going to call the test function
let's say this function does one thing
which is defines variable a and it's
number one and it defines variable B
which is number two so does a plus
B and assign it to my C so if we save
this and we run the logic it's going to
say it's on Def because we are
explicitly returning on death if we
remove this return statement and call
the function is going to return 3. so
sometimes you don't actually want to
return the last value which you
calculated from your function but only
do the calculations and do some printing
or call another function but the problem
is that if you don't explicitly say that
hey I didn't want to return anything
then it might be confusing for the color
it's just a good practice to say either
you want to return C explicitly as such
or or you don't want to return anything
as we did initially it's by saying I'm
deaf now as promised I did say before
that we're going to explore subroutine
signatures subroutine signatures were
introduced in pro version 5.1a and it
was classified as experimental until
5.34 however the experimental warning
was removed at 5.36 which is the version
currently I'm working with when making
this video If I say pro version I'm
going to say that this is 5.36 a very
good timing to explore subroutines know
how you can use hypertensive signatures
is by using this program called use
feature and then you import a specific
feature you want to use in this case you
can use code word notation that we
looked at before and since it's a single
name we can say signatures
and that's it we should now be able to
use signatures in our Pro code
let's remove this body syntax and let's
return back to the print
hello
exclamation mark let me call on let's
invoke our function as such
let's remove the print
and let's say we wanted to print out the
name so how we did it before we were
passing in an argument in this context
which we then got from this special
array which is at symbol underscore now
with signatures we can actually Define
what arguments are going to receive in
this function so if I say parentheses
and I'm gonna say that I want to receive
a name if I run this it's going to
complain it's going to say too few
Arguments for subroutine main package
which is file and test and it says that
it got zero unexpected one and that's
true because we're requesting one
argument and by default if you use
subroutine signatures and you define
arguments as such they are required and
since I'm not passing an argument here
it complains I can fix that by saying
John again save the file we run the
script and it works it says hello John
so what if you didn't want to have
mandatory arguments you can use equals
notation and set the value to undefined
which means that the default we're not
set is going to be undefined or you can
just say for example a string
which is Bob so if there is no argument
provided for this test function
then I want this argument which is name
they have a value of Bob if I rerun this
it's going to say hello Bob now one
thing to note is that if you do want to
have an argument which is required you
must have it before the argument which
is not required so let's say name is
optional but last name isn't so I need
to have the last name before the name
otherwise you're going to get a warning
that says your positioning of arguments
is not correct so I save this and rerun
the file
oh we added a character that we don't
want so if I rerun the file now it's
going to say too few arguments expected
at least one argument so because we
expected last name so we can set the
last name to just last let's save this
rerun
oh rerun a crypt and it's gonna say
hello Bob you can also pass a named
argument such as using hashes
so I said these are my inputs
and I just want to do one thing which is
print dumper
to do it's lowercase dumper backslash
inputs I'm going to print actually the
reference of this hash because it gives
us a better visual structure to debug
what they're passing here so if I do
this and let's say I have number one
which is going to hold a value of one
and number two which is going to hold a
value of 2. save this rerun the script
it's going to say that what we got here
in the inputs named argument input which
is Hash which we reference this is where
we get this file my structure is a key
that points to Value 1 and key 2 which
points to Value two and this is very
nice if you want to use named arguments
because it allows you explicitly say
what you want to pass in so choose last
name first name and so on now the last
thing I want to show you is something
that's called a Slurpee capture and this
is basically array which captures all
the given arguments and you don't need
to name them for example if I say at
inputs
and I want to say that my first actual
required input is name but anything that
we pass in afterwards is not being
required or we don't want to set default
values so what I can do I can print out
the name but we're going to get and I
can also print out through dumper the
inputs we're going to get so again we're
getting array right so we're capturing
all in Array what we're going to print
out array reference by using this
backslash just for better formatting so
now if the first argument is set to
let's say John
we print it out
it's going to say that yes the first
item we got is John what we got now
weather up elements and this is because
we didn't pass anything extra now if we
want to pass more values 1 2 3 maybe
let's open a hash here as well with
items a b and c and if I save this
here we go so the variable one argument
one is John this is what we're printing
out here for this number function and
the variable one for the second dumper
print function holds value one two three
and a hash F which we passed in here and
this is using square brackets because we
are referencing our array inputs now
this is it for this video we looked at
what are subroutines how to create and
interact with them we also explore Pro
subroutine signatures and various ways
how you can Define them I hope you found
this video useful and I'll see you at
the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore variable
Scopes in previous lecture we saw how we
can use subroutines and we also notice
that if you define my and then the
variable and then my variable inside the
subroutine those names will not Clash
because there is a difference between
Scopes when you would try to Define a
variable twice with the same name in the
same scope for example in this file
you're currently looking at you will get
a warning these differences are called
Global scope and local scope we saw the
my keyword I can say my bar equals value
one however there is a another way how
you can Define your variables and that
is by using our keyword so we can say or
variable equals one I can print it out
by saying print
Thumper
bar now if I go to console and type
Pearl crypt.pl I'm going to see variable
one on Surface this might not be visible
why it might be useful so let's explore
where this actually does come handy and
that is when we're trying to use a
script in another script we will look
into future lectures of how we can use
and require files and what is the
difference between these two but for now
let's just create a new file through new
file and call it script
or script2.pl
what we can do we can go back to our
script file and let's copy everything
what we see here on my Mac I'm using
command C and I'm going to go into
script two paste that all in I'm going
to print out
and hello from script
save it up go to my script the original
script one and I'm going to use this
special keyword which is called require
and I'm going to require my script 2
file since my script 2 file is currently
next to my script.pl I can use dot
notation forward slash which says use
the relative path to this folder and
script to that PL
and ended the semicolon I'm going to
remove these values for now I'm going to
save script.pl and go back to the
console I'm going to run the script.br
which is spiral move that
PL
what I'm going to see is Hello from
script 2. so that means that when we
require this file the script 2 we
actually got the print statement invoked
but what if for example we had some
variables we wanted to use in our script
to let's say these variable is called my
script to underscore VAR equals secret
so if I save this and I'm actually going
to comment out this hello from script 2.
go back to script 1 and I will try to do
print script to underscore VAR
save this go to the console
I'm going to say bubble symbols group 2
wall records explicit package name it
hasn't been declared but it's strange
because we are requiring script 2 and
there is a variable script to underscore
VAR so why is it complaining well again
it's due to the scope so by default if
you use my keyword the scope is
currently to this file this variable is
not exposed to the script.pl file now if
we wanted to expose this variable to
script 2 this is where the or keyword
comes into play you can change my to or
go back to script.pl try to rerun
however as you can see it's still not
working so another thing we need to do
is we need to explicitly Define that we
want to pull in this variable from
script to file otherwise we're going to
get this warning and this is because of
the progress you need to be explicitly
requiring this variable so there is no
confusion whatsoever and you can do this
by saying or brackets for a list of
variables we might want to Define and
I'm going to say I want my script to
underscore War save it go back to the
console try to run the pro script file
again and it works what we got here is
we said print script to war which holds
a string called secret and this is in
script two so we actually could access
the variable 2 by explicitly saying we
want to use globally scoped variable
called Script to VAR and we want to pull
this into this script and print it out
from this file now in last lecture what
we saw was this use feature and
subroutines but we can use another
feature which is called state
and state is a special keyword used
before your variables which tells your
script that this variable should be
initialized once and only once in a
memory throughout the execution of
script what do I mean by that well if we
try to introduce a subroutine let's say
test
and curly brackets and let's say I want
to say my bar
which is a scalar equals one and I'm
going to print out
bar plus 1
and concatenate it with new line
so if I call Disk function test David go
to the console I'm gonna see two a
little bit nudged there so let's maybe
add a string before that
concatenate that and go back to the
console
of course because now we need to wrap it
in Brackets to explicitly Define that we
have a string context we want to
concatenate with the context where we're
actually adding numbers and then
concatenate that context with a new line
so you can use parentheses to kind of
isolate your context if you go to
console try to print it again we're
going to say greater than and two and
what if we want to recall this function
many times
we run it again you can say 22222 and
this is because every single time we're
using my in a code block this variable
is initialized each time we call the
test function but what if we didn't want
to do that what if we actually wanted to
initialize this variable only once and
keep track of this value every time we
execute this function well we can use
the keyword state so if I replace my
with State save the file go to the
console and rerun or test functions
which are being called five times and we
actually need to change things up if you
think about it the value didn't change
because we are saying variable equals
one and that was initialized once but we
are adding variable plus 1 and not
increasing it we're just adding one to
variable and then printing it out it's
not actually setting that variable to
higher number so how we can increase
that number is by removing this and
saying variable to concatenate it
and here we want to do VAR plus equals
one if we save this the script
so now we're gonna see two three four
five and just to verify that it actually
works as expected if I change state to I
save it you run it then say 222 as I
mentioned before using my decoration
every time we enter this code block it
sets it to 1 incremented by one and then
prints it out using state if I change it
back
we initialize it once to number one and
we keep incrementing this variable which
is defined once in a memory
and if I rerun this again we can say two
three four five six now where can this
be useful you might find yourself in
scenarios where you're creating Maps
lookup maps of some keys values which
are never going to change in your
program such as translations or special
use case mappings in this case you don't
really want to initialize your map every
single time what I mean by this you
could say state
map
equals a
1 b equals 2 and C equals three and if I
wanted to Simply print what's in the map
by accessing what was passed into
arguments so we're going to use the
dollar sign underscore remember because
all the arguments are in at underscore
and to access a single element we could
use dollar sign underscore and then
square brackets which is the first
argument
so if we just wanted to print out the
first argument from this map we can use
State because this is never going to
change a is going to be pointing to one
C is going to always be pointing to 3 in
this scenario and if you remove this and
add let's say a to print out yes looks
like we're actually saying that this is
a hash using array ref syntax so we
should be using braces if I move this
into here
set up remove the curly brackets and
rerun it forget the semicolon and this
is good it's always good to read your
errors in this case I did not add a
semicolon in the line 19 it says that
there was an error we couldn't print it
and this is because there was no
semicolon had it on line 17. it actually
gives you a suggestion where it's a
syntax error on line 20 near early
bracket which refers back to previous
error the or map wasn't defined while it
was defined but it wasn't defined
properly if we save it go back to the
console rerun it you can see number one
so this is it for this video we looked
at different Scopes and how you would
apply them in practice we saw scenarios
where you might want to use all keyword
when required multiple scripts or you
might consider using State keyword to
initialize your data once and only once
in memory for execution of your script
lifetime I hope you found this video
useful and I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore how we can
handle exceptions in Pearl specifically
we will look into how we can throw
exceptions and how to safely capture
exceptions in general exceptions happen
all the time unfortunately even in
production for example if you try to
access a database that is not available
or you try to read write a file that
doesn't exist or read them all from Json
so on and so on if such exceptions
happen we might want to handle them
gracefully and recover in the code
without breaking the functionality of
our script so let's see how we can
handle exceptions in Pearl the throne
exception you can use this keyword
called died now whenever this is invoked
an exception is going to be thrown and
our script is not going to execute the
code which is followed after the die
statement for example if I add a prints
hello called the new line save this
printer Scripts I'm going to see that
our script dot at line 7 and nothing was
printed out because our print statement
followed after die exception and
execution of our code did not continue
after line 7. if I would move this line
before that statement save this rerun
our script file it's going to print
hello and then it's going to die at line
8. it's also worth noting that you can
throw named exceptions such as die
cannot go on if we save this rerun our
script file we're going to see Hello
printed and then cannot go on at line 8.
now this is how you control exceptions
in Pro now the question is how you can
handle them now to handle exceptions in
Pro you can use this keyword called Evo
followed by opening and closing curly
brackets
and ending with semicolon if we move
this die block inside Evol and move this
print block after the UL run our code
we're going to see that our script
executed as we expected so hello was
printed to the terminal and we do not
see that the execution of the script
stopped however what I said before
regards to the code not executing after
exception is drawn still applies inside
ewall block to demonstrate let's
introduce a new variable which is my
test and assign world as a value
and then we're going to interpolate this
into the Sprint statement by saying
hello variable test
run this it prints hello world as
expected because we Define our variable
before Evol and then we print our hello
and this variable interpolated however
if I would try to reassign a value let's
say test equals Bob
save this go to the terminal and run our
script it's going to say hello world and
why is that well we did declare our
variable test and we assign a string
world
then we try to assign a string Bob to
our test variable and print it out again
however inside our Evo block we also
threw an exception and once this
exception was thrown we never got around
assigning the value of Bob to our test
variable now how can we know when an
exception was drawn well pro has a
special keyword for this and whenever
exception occurs and is being captured
in Evo block the value of that exception
is going to be assigned in dollar sign
at symbol So currently this variable
holds the name of our exception you can
use this variable for example to print
out if an exception was drawn so if I
move this into our print statement so
semicolon paste it here save our script
file and run it again we're going to see
the hello world semicolon and then
cannot go on at script line 10. now this
can be useful if you want to compare if
a value was set in the special variable
now if you want to execute a specific a
code for example if you would comment
out die statement go to the terminal
print it out again it's going to say
hello Bob So currently our dollar sign
at variable has no exception so no
exception was drawn we are going to see
later on our lectures how to use logical
statements to compare if values are set
and you can execute different type of
logic based on if there is or isn't a
value in the special variable now
alternatively if you just want to say
that something did not happen according
to the plan but you don't want to stop
the execution of your script you can use
a keyword called warn and this one is
going to print to the standard error
output if I say warn something is not
right
save this
run our script oops and looks like we
left the test variable here so let's
remove that and we also let's remove
This Global variable and just print
hello rerun our script we're going to
see something is not quite right which
is what we warned about on line six but
our script actually got here on line 8
of printing hello so warn is something
that prints to the standard error
outputs but it does not stop the
execution of your script and it's very
handy if you want to notify when things
go wrong but it's not on a level that it
might break your script logic so you're
happy to proceed to note this is a basic
out of the box approach and how to
handle exceptions in Pro there is a much
better way to troll and capture named
exceptions that we will look into the
future lecture so this is it for this
video we looked at how we control and
handle exceptions in pearls out of the
box solution I hope you found this video
useful and I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture
this video we will explore logical
operators in Pearl we already looked at
operators used for addition and
subtraction of numbers we also looked at
into how we can concatenate strings now
there are many more operators you can
use to compare if your numbers are equal
or if your strings are equal or number
is greater or less or maybe they're
equal so let's explore this concept of
logical operators before we do that I do
want to introduce you to a ternary
statement an a ternary statement is a
block which takes an expression followed
by question mark and then it returns a
result which is at position 1 if it's
true followed by colon and another
expression if it's false for example if
I want to say print something which is a
ternary expression like one which
evaluates truthy then I want to print
yes otherwise if it's not true we use
colon as mentioned before
and we're gonna say no we go to the
console say pearlscript.pl it's going to
say yes because this is expression which
needs to evaluate to true for us to
print yes and if it won't be true it
would print no in Pro all the truthy
values are 1 or a string which is of
length at least one references are
truthy because they're going to point to
memory even Anonymous references if
you're not the scalers or a negative
number no falsy value is anything which
is for example 0 undefined or empty
string so if I want to say print is on
dev truthy rerun the script it's going
to say no it's not truthy so same goes
for example if I want to say is
anti-string truthy no it's not no one
gotcha Pearl is that a string which
holds a value of 0 is actually a falsy
you would expect that if it's a string
it holds a number which is zero so
technically it's not of a length 0 which
I mentioned before but there is an
exception if you say number one
this is truth a and the final falsy
value is zero so if you run this it's
going to say no now let's try to do some
comparisons with numbers but before we
move forwards I would like to introduce
you to a feature
feature which is called say and say it's
just a handy function which
automatically adds a new line at the end
of whatever we're printing so I can say
something which is the same statement
and I rerun this it's going to print
note or console but as you can see it
adds a new line so it's kind of handier
than using print and then manually
appending a new line and in specially
cases where you're debugging things you
might not consider just using a save
function which automatically does this
appending of new one so now let's start
with comparing numbers let's say I want
to check if one equals to zero and how
you can do that is by using this double
equals Mark it's going to compare if one
equals 0 and if it is it's going to
print yes and if it's not then it's
going to print now so I've tried to
print this I'm getting now because well
one is not equal to zero you can also
reverse this and say is one not equal to
zero I'm just gonna print yes one is not
equal to zero you can also compare if
one is going greater than 0 which should
give you yes it 1 is greater than zero
and the opposite is one less than zero
which is going to give you no one is not
less than zero you can also combine less
than and greater operators using the
less than or greater operator followed
by equals you can see that is 1 less
than or equal to 0 if we try to print it
out no and is one greater or equal to
zero is going to say yes because 1 is
greater or equal to zero the same thing
would be if I would say is 0 greater or
equal to 0 well 0 is not greater than
zero but it is equal to zero so this is
going to print yes now there is also
this special operator called three-way
comparison which is basically going to
return you
-1 0 or 1 depending of if the values
you're comparing are less than equal or
greater this is very useful when you
want to use it in function options like
sorting or mapping things but probably
you wouldn't use it on daily basis that
often however let's take a look at this
operator so if I say something and I'm
gonna say is one then we use this keyway
comparison operator also known as
spaceship operator because it goes like
less than equals greater than one and
that's all I want to print I just want
to print the result of this and I want
to comment out the previous line it's
comparing if one equals 1 which is zero
so we're getting zero because value on
our left hand side is equal to the value
to the right hand side now if I set the
value on right hand side to zero Which
is less than one and I print this out
give it back to one but it's not the one
what we're printing out here I could
change this to 20 print it out and I'm
going to say still one because it's a
three-way comparison one zero minus one
and now if I change the 0 to 40 which is
actually bigger than 20 we're gonna get
minus one so you're gonna get one 1 if
the value on your left hand side is
larger than the value on your right hand
side 0 if both values are equal or -1 if
the value on your right hand side is
larger than the value on your left hand
side now let's look at strings strings
are very similar we have the same
comparison logic which you can say for
example is a equal or greater 2B however
you need to use this special keywords
instead of less than equals then or
greater than operators and the
equivalent comparison operators for
strings are called equal which X is a
equal to B and that's a no because a is
not equal to B then there's also not
equal is a not equal to B which is yes a
is not equal to B now the next thing is
LT for less than
and BTS because a is less than b in
alphabetical order I could swap this
around and say is B less than a can be
no because B follows after a and there's
also greater than which is GT and if
this prints out yes because is B greater
than a which is yes because B follows
after a and if I swap this around I
would get no you also get equivalent
operators for less than or equals so you
can use l e or less than or equals so is
B less than or equals to A which is no
it's neither equal or less than but if I
change a to B is going to give that give
us yes because b equals B and if I
change this to c I'm also going to get
yes because is B less than C yes it is
less than but it's not equals however it
pass the first condition so we get yes
and as you have guessed we also have
greater or equal so you can use g e for
greater equals now the question is B
greater than or equal to C no however is
C greater than or equal to C which is
yes because C equals c see so we get yes
we can also check this with d so is D
greater than or equal to C yes yes it is
because D comes after C now another
useful thing you can do in Pro is you
can change your Expressions such as two
or more Expressions has to be true in
order to print or positive scenario
which is the yes string or you can say
one or the other scenario has to be true
in order to print all positive scenario
let's look at simple example we could
say one is bigger than zero and we
should use two ampersines two is bigger
than one if we run this we're going to
see yes printed to a terminal and this
is because our left hand side expression
was true and or right hand side
expression was true and that means we
printed out the yes string however if I
would change one to three and try to run
the script again it's going to print no
and this is because our left hand side
still evaluates the true however or
right hand side now evaluates to false
and we're indicating with two ampersines
that both of these Expressions have to
be true in order to go into the positive
scenario which is printing out the yes
keyword now if you only cared about one
or the other expression being true you
can use these two pipes which will show
you mean or so now we're saying if the
left hand side condition is true or the
right hand side condition is true then
print out yes I'll run this it's going
to print yes and what Pro does it goes
in this left hand side it evaluates if
it's truthy and if it is truthy it's not
going to even check the next Expressions
because we know already that our
scenario passes so we can print out the
yes string and you can change these
Expressions even further by using
brackets such as I could say if one is
larger than 0 and I encapsulate these
with parentheses
and let's say if 2 is bigger than 3 or 1
is bigger than 0 save this is going to
print yes if we bisect this we're going
to see that 1 is bigger than 0 and 1 or
the other condition encapsulated after
two ampere signs is true which in this
case 2 is not larger than 3 however one
is larger than zero we're going to print
yes string if we would change this to to
amperscience it basically means that all
the conditions have to be truthy if we
rerun the script we're going to see no
because now our second condition doesn't
pass and that means there is no point to
evaluate the right hand side expression
because we know all Expressions did not
pass all the necessary conditions and
you can use this logic even with
comparing strings as we saw before we
looked at less than equals than or
greater or equals than and so on it's
not just the numbers let's quickly look
at assignment operators and some
shortcuts you already know that we can
initialize new variable let's say a num
that holds a value of 20 using equal
sign and let's try to say this num
our console if we save it run it we get
print20 and now what if we wanted to add
a number we saw that we can add
something to a number by saying num
equals num Plus
five so we're going to get 25 but you
can use a shortcut and the shortcut is
plus equal five and if we run this we
can see 25 again so basically what this
does it says add 5 to the same variable
we're currently working with so add plus
5 to this num variable it's just a neat
way to do additions instead of writing
the full num plus 5 and so on and as you
imagine you can also use minus equals if
you print this one out we get 15 and we
can use all the mathematical operators
for example if we want to use the
multiplication we can use Asterix or
print this out we get 100 or we can use
division
and we're going to get four because we
are dividing self with 5 which is 4 so
we set the num to four and so on we have
very similar shortcut to Strings as well
so if I say my string for SDR equals
hello
to append something to string you could
say string equals string
dot notation base
for old exclamation mark
but if we say this one out
you can see hello world if we want to
quickly append something we can say that
equals which is going to give us hello
world now there's another interesting
operator which is called repetition
operator and it allows you to repeat a
string multiple times and you repeat it
by writing X very similar to
multiplication as you write it on paper
but in Pearl X is to multiply string so
let's say if we wanted to multiply h x
times we can use H character X for
multiplication 6 and then we print out
the string is going to print HHH and if
we just add a space to make it more
clearer we're going to print out h space
h space and so on and so on you can also
use operators to increment or decrement
things for example my num which equals
10 and we can say num plus plus
and say the num we print this out we can
see that num is 11 or we can decrement
num by saying num
minus minus
equals 9. so it might not seem that it's
quite useful at this point but it does
become useful in loops and statements
where we calculate things and we will
look into that in our next lecture just
a final side note is that these are not
all the available logical operators in
Pro however these are definitely the
ones you will find yourself using the
most and this is it for this video we
looked at different operators in Pro how
you put them in practice in strings
numbers and when you're trying to
compare them between each other I hope
you found this video useful and I'll see
you at the next one
in this video we will explore
conditional statements in Pearl so what
is a conditional statement conditional
statement is a block of code that will
be executed if one or more Expressions
at the beginning of the conditional
block evaluates through furthermore
conditional statements can be extended
with additional cases to execute
different logic based on given
Expressions this all might sound
confusing but don't worry let's look at
some basic examples to make it easier to
understand we already explored one of
the conditional statements in our
previous lectures and that conditional
statement is called turnarate statement
this is where you give expression
followed by a question mark and a block
of logic you want to execute if the
expression is true otherwise followed by
colon block of logic you want to execute
if it falls just repeat it again with
the example we could say AKA printer
console if 2 is larger than one then we
want to print out hello
otherwise we want to print out world if
we save this run our code oops we need a
semicolon at the end if this run our
code again we're going to see Hello
printed in our console this is because 2
is larger than 1 and we print it out
hello now we could execute the opposite
case if we would reverse this
conditional check which would evaluate
to false for example we could say is 1
larger than one run our code with
proscript.pl and we're gonna see World
printed out to our console this is
because one is not larger than one one
is equal to one now this is a basic
example what if we wanted to execute
more logic not just printing out single
string well we could use a conditional
statement by saying if
or logic bracket where you have to
provide expression that the value is the
true followed by opening and curly
braces and let's add some code there
let's say I want to print out hello and
I also want to print out world now let's
add an expression in our if statement
and say if 2 is larger than 1 they have
the file run the code crawl script.pl
you're going to see two things printed
out we could also do more Expressions
such as we could Define a variable
saying my VAR equals one and then we
could print it out by saying my VAR then
interpolate that variable into a string
save it run the code again we're going
to see Hello rolled and my War which
holds the value of 1. you can add a lot
of logic and other expressions in the if
block that needs to be executed in the
condition beginning at the if block
evaluates to true now what happens for
example if I say if 1 is larger than one
let's save this run our code we're going
to see nothing printed to our console
this is because one is not larger than
one so this block of code does not
execute we are not seeing anything in
the console in cases where our
expression didn't evaluate to true we
could use another keyword called else
followed by opening and curly brackets
and then we could print something like
this is else part at semicolon save this
rerun or script you're going to see this
is else part into the inner console you
could actually extend this conditional
statements even further for example I
could say if my variable which is test
equals 1 and then I could compare if
test is larger than one and use a
keyword which is else
if written with Els if so you don't
write the full else word followed Again
by opening and closing brackets and
let's say if test
equals one with two equal signs and add
curly brackets and then we could say
something like middle part error code go
to console
run the script and we're going to see
middle printed out in our terminal you
can add as many as else if blocks as you
want however do note that if you have
those blocks that meet two different
conditions that evaluate the true let's
say I have first elsif that evaluates it
through and the second L save but if I
wanted to print out middle 2 go to
console run the script it's just going
to print the middle part so the key
point to remember here is that these
blocks of code execute in sequential
order and once a true three condition is
met the execution of your code stops so
this first part did not evaluate to true
but the second part did since it's
evaluated to true the rest of the code
did not run now another keyword you
could use is unless and unless it works
exactly like if but opposite so meaning
if your condition evaluates to false
then your code is going to be run for
example if I type unless opening and
closing parentheses say if test is
larger than 2
say this is a negative case save this
run our script again and the same as
with if blocks you could extend it
further with else if and put your
conditions here
and end it with else however do note
that unless can be quite tricky to
understand especially if you want to add
multiple conditions from my experience
you really need to stop and think what
this keyword is actually meaning because
it basically says if not true and if you
have many conditions in that unless
Block it's just going to get very very
confusing however do know that you can
use unless in conditional assignments
which becomes extremely useful and much
more easier to read than saying if not
condition let's see what I mean by that
for example if I want to print out this
test variable by saying bar
test and let's say I wanted to change
the test value to 2 if 2 is larger than
1. if you run this we're going to see
bar equals to printed to our console
because with the final variable with a
value of one and then we assign value 2
if this expression is true we could also
say assign a value of 2
unless 3 is larger than 2. if we save
this from the code we're going to see
War equals one this is because we're
saying our variable equals to 1 and then
we're saying assign value of 2 to our
variable unless 3 is larger than 2 well
3 is not larger than 2 and that means 2
is never assigned to this variable and
this is one of my favorite features in
Pro because you don't need to use
ternary Expressions to reassign values
if you come from different programming
languages you might know that you have
to use ternary Expressions such as test
equals 2 and then you need to provide
your condition such as 3 is larger than
2 if yes then value equals 2 otherwise
value equals one if we print this then
we see that the value of 2 was assigned
because 3 is larger than 2 in Pro you
can say list equals three if two is
larger than one we print this out again
here we go this now holds a value of
three this is it for this video
hopefully the conditional statements and
using conditional statements in
assignment context are much clearer now
and you feel more comfortable using them
in practice I hope you found this video
useful and I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore Loops in Pro
so what is a loop well Loop is a very
similar to the conditional statement
principle we looked at before however
instead of running the code once in a
conditional statement the code in the
loop will be executed multiple times
while the expression in the beginning of
the loop evaluates the true let's look
at different Loops in Pro and some
examples on how to use them and the
first Loop we are going to look at is
the while loop you construct your while
loop by typing while opening and closing
parentheses and then opening and closing
early brackets as you might have guessed
you put your expression inside the
parentheses as with a conditional
statement now here you could say
something like while 2 is larger than 1
we want to print hello
rolled if I run this now this is
actually going to cause infinite Loop
because this file condition is always
going to pass meaning is going to print
hello world all the time to the console
let's add a condition which is going to
tell us when the while loop should stop
running for example let's introduce a
variable as before test equals one
and here we could say while
test is less than 10 if you want to
print out hello world
now let's add the test variable here as
well if I save this
from the script looks like we're
actually causing infinite Loop and the
reason is because we are never actually
incrementing the test variable which is
causing the while loop to run
indefinitely so what we could do as we
saw before we could use this post
increment with plus plus so meaning
every single time we're going to hit the
while loop we're going to print hello
world and our variable test and then
we're going to increment the test
variable by one and this is going to run
while test is less than 10. if we save
this run our code again
we're going to see Hello World and or
variable value printed afterwards so
this runs nine times while the test is
less than 10 and you can add different
kind of Expressions which need to
evaluate the true well some sort of
condition is not met and once your
condition is met you can exit the while
loop in this case we're using a test
variable which are incrementing well
it's less than 10. but your case can be
different now another loop we could use
is the for Loop and it's very similar to
while loop meaning we have to give it a
condition that needs to evaluate for the
loop to run knows when to exit however
the difference is here we provide init
variable followed by the expression that
needs to evaluate the true or The Loop
to run and then we need to provide a
handle of how our initial variable
should be incremented or decremented for
expression to keep running let's look at
some examples such as say
hello a test variable and save this and
now let's replace the blocks that we
need to initialize in order for for Loop
to run so we could say my test starting
value equals zero
then the expression could be while test
is less than 10.
and the handle could be test
plus so we're initializing a test
variable to zero we're running the loop
while the test variable is less than 10
and afterwards we're incrementing this
variable by one we save this
run our script we're going to see value
of 0 printed up to the nine and you can
of course reverse this by subtracting a
value then checking where the value is
less than X or similar cases now another
loop in Pro we're going to look at is
called for each Loop and for each Loop
basically goes through every single
element in the given list and once it
reaches the last element it's going to
sub the execution for example we could
say for each my
item and then we could provide a list
and very similar to previous cases we're
going to say hello and we're going to
print out item save this and another
thing we need to do we need to define
the list so I'm going to say that my
list is going to hold values from 1 to
10 and we saw in our previous lecture is
that what this basically does is two dot
symbols is going to construct a list by
populating the items from 1 till 10 so
it's going to go one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten if I save this
run our script
I'm going to see an item is printed to
the console so what the for each Loop
did it went through every single item
which we declared in local scope inside
the list and it printed out in the loop
now for the warning here if you're
coming from other programming languages
you might expect that when you're
iterating through a list then you're
modifying item in place is going to
modify a copy of an item in that list
and pro this is not the case when you're
modifying an item in a loop it's
actually going to modify the item in the
given list so what I mean by that is for
example if we said orange my item I
could say item equals
light time plus one which could also be
written as plus equals one if we print
this out we're going to see two three
four ten eleven because now every single
item is incremented by one however if we
exit the forage Loop and we print out by
a dumper or list by referencing it
because it's going to give us a nicer
structure if you rerun the script or go
to the semicolon if we rerun our script
again we're going to see that here we go
we printed out two three four five seven
and so on because we incremented an item
in the loop however afterwards once we
printed our list all the items on the
list actually changed so in our original
list we had items from 1 till 10 then we
incremented that item by one inside a
loop and this changed the items in place
in the list we were working with so just
a word a warning whenever you're working
with loops and you're modifying values
just remember that you're modifying the
values in the list
another useful thing you can do with the
loops you can miss them for example if
we introduce a new list let's call it
nesteds and we're going to add only two
items here it's going to be one and two
let's go inside our four each Loop let's
remove this addition and now let's go
through our nested Loop items so I'm
going to say for each
my nested item
the list of nested items
I'm going to print something with
backslash t or tab so that we can better
see it in our console I'm going to say
nested and I'm going to print out the
nested item if I save this go to the
terminal run the script let's remove
this dumper so we have a better
visibility let's rerun our script we're
going to see now is that we have hello
one and afterwards we have nested
printed out hello2 and nested one and
two so what happens here is that we go
through each item in the list starting
with one and in every iteration we're
running an inner loop and that inner
loop goes through all the items in this
array called nested so we hit the first
item then we go through one two that we
can see in the terminal here then we go
to the second item which is in the main
Loop and we go through all the items
which are in the Inner Loop so on and so
on you can Nest many Loops as you want
just do be careful because the behavior
can become quite unpredictable if you
have many nested Loops it will become
very hard to follow the logic very
quickly you might find yourself in
scenarios where you actually want to
exit a loop or you maybe want to skip to
the next item and for this Pearl has
some couple of keywords to control your
Loops these keywords are next last redo
and go to let's take a look at the next
keyword so for example we can introduce
something like next if or item equals
two so if we save this we run our script
and if we look at the output what we're
going to see is that we printed out the
main Loop and the nested Loop statements
however when we went to the second Loop
item we draw the value of 2 we did print
out a hello item from the main lobe
however we did not print items in a
nested Loop and this is because we used
next keyword and the control statement
of if as we saw in previous lectures
that says go to the next iteration if
the current item where iterating has a
value of 2. so the execution which
followed afterwards never happens we can
also use the keyword such as last as the
name implies you might figure out that
this keyword simply ends the loop as
saying that this is the last iteration
we want to execute so if we save this go
to our terminal let's clear it up we run
our code we're going to see that we went
through the first item and also through
the nested Loop however once I hit the
second item we printed out the first
statement because it's before the last
keyword but we never get around the
forage Inner Loop and this is because we
said that we want this to be the last
iteration if the value of the item
equals 2. we can also use a keyword redo
and again as the name implies it's going
to redo the same Loop if the item value
matches of what we're looking for if I
clear the console we run the script with
pearlscript.pl oh this is actually going
to result in infinite Loop and the
infinite Loop Accord because we printed
out the first item that had earlier one
then we went to the next item which has
a value of 2 and we say redo this Loop
if value equals 2. now since we're
redoing this Loop the value is always
two this causes infinite Loop now what
we could do here we could increment item
by one save this rerun our script and
whatever we're going to observe here is
that we actually printed one then we
incremented item by plus 1 and that
means it now holds a value of 2. so we
redid the loop however the value now is
3 meaning this statement executed it
redid the loop since the value now is 4
the actual never print out the nested
Loop so we skip this part by
incrementing item by one redoing the law
with incremented value and moving to the
next item in the list now there's also
this keyword go to for this to be
executed we will need to talk about
named loops and basically what named
Loops are you can add this keyword
before your Loop in uppercase such as
Loop 1 followed by column and then we
can say Loop two now what we could do
here instead of printing hello actually
let's leave the printing of hello but
before this printing of the outer loop
let's add the statement that's going to
say go to Loop
to if item equals one we save this we
run our code and let's observe the
results what we're gonna see now is that
we do have hello two printed out to the
console and the nested Loop afterwards
however in this scenario which is the
first one where the value is one in the
main Loop we don't have anything printed
that says hello one and this is because
we are saying if the item value in the
first iteration equals 1 or well in any
iteration for that matter we want to
stop the execution which is in between
the go to statement and the loop which
you're saying go to Just execute the
next Loop and then bloops are quite
handy when you're using nested Loops you
can apply these names for keywords as
next or last if you want to be specific
which exactly Loop you're referring to
so what I mean by that is if we remove
this part let's leave the say hello item
which is in our main Loop let's go to
the Inner Loop and after printing nested
I'm going to say last Loop 1
if item
equals one we save this we run our code
we're going to see Hello one printed
then nested one printed and that's it
and this is because again we went
through the main Loop we printed item
one here then we're going to Second Loop
we print the first item in the nested
Loop but then we say last Loop which is
named one and refers to the outer loop
if the item value is one is the first
item in the list has a value one and
that's it we're done with execution so
name Loops are quite handy if you want a
granular control of the loop execution
when you have nested Loops this is it
for this video we looked at Loops in
Pearl and how you can apply them in
practice I hope you found this video
useful and I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore what are
regular Expressions also known as
Rejects and how to use them in Pro in
nutshell a regular expression is a
string of characters and symbols that
Define the pattern you want to match
against your string value you might have
heard the Pearl is very powerful when it
comes to using regular expressions and
that is quite true it is extremely easy
to use rejects in Pro and there are
various tools baked into Pro to match
you and modify your data using regular
Expressions let's look at some examples
of using reject system Pro we'll be
using conditional statement to see if
all rejects is true so we can do if
something is true then let's say again
print something to the console which is
going to be matches with exclamation
mark now how you can match your rejects
by giving a variable such as test then
equal sign followed by tilde and two
forward leaning slashes and then you
could add your character matching such
as dog if I would Define my variable and
say test equals Cat Let's also introduce
false expression and let's say
does not match
save this run our script
we're going to see that this does not
match and it makes sense because we're
testing if this variable called test
matches a pattern which is dog now if we
try to match something like dog
rerun our script we're going to see yes
it matches and you can add other strings
such as cat and mouse and in between
there we can have dog and it's going to
say matches because the rejects looks at
all of the string and looks for this
particular pattern of dog inside that
string its or string contains cat dog
Mouse and it has dog between it matches
so it prints out patches now what if you
actually wanted to test for something
like is there a forward learning slash
inside the rejects and if we run our Pro
script now it's going to say oof there
is a syntax error and that makes sense
because all rejects pattern is defined
by two forward leaning slashes so by
adding the third slash it invalids
syntax so one of the Alternatives is to
use backslash and backslash is basically
escaping these special characters and
they're going to be understood literal
characters so here we're looking for
literal board leaning slash in our
string if we rerun this again this does
not match because our string does not
have a four leaning slash but if we add
that here after dog save this and on our
script again it matches alternative is
you can use this m modifier and what M
modifier allows you to do is change the
wrapping syntax of your pattern so we
can use something like Curly brackets
instead of forward leaning slashes to
build our pattern if we rerun this again
it says it matches and without the M
modifier this becomes invalid syntax and
it's already cleaned by the syntax
highlighter by the code editor if we
rerun it basically says something is not
right with your code you can also add
some modifiers so first if we fix this
and dog and forward learning slash we
run this this is fine so you could
actually try to match something at the
beginning of the string at the end of
the string by using this roof character
and then dollar sign so this means that
your string the pattern you're looking
for has to be exactly dog forward slash
from the beginning and the end of the
string so now if we rerun this we're
going to see does not match because
there is a cat and a mouse wrapping or
pattern we're looking for if we remove
the Cat part and we remove the mouse
part we have this rerun our script
you're going to see that it matches you
can also use special rejects keywords
such as to look for a character or look
for a number or something that is
another character or not a number and
you can do this by saying backwards
leaning slash and for a any word
character you could say w and here if we
amend the string to say dogs
rerun our script we're going to see that
it matches because now we're looking for
anything that is dog followed by a
character so this extra character is s
not to match something that is not a
character you can use capital W and I'm
going to add a resource link which is
going to tell you what exactly is
considered and is not considered a word
character let's add a hyphen character
and rerun our script we're going to see
that this matches because hyphen is well
considered a word character you could
also use like slash D and backslash D is
a number let's say if you're matching
against dog one save this run the script
it's going to say matches because we're
looking at something that is beginning
to the end containing dog followed by
number so since one is a number and this
matches so what if we added another
number save this rerun our script it's
going to say it does not match because
here we are looking for exactly one
number after the string dog so we could
do something like plus so that means
we're looking for one or more number
after a dog we can add more numbers save
this we run our script and it's going to
say matches we could also use star
instead of plus if we run this it's
going to say matches now what star does
it basically says there can or cannot be
a number and we don't really care so we
can match against dog exactly or there
could be numbers such as these and if we
save this we run it matches in both
scenarios now what if we want to say I
want a dog and two numbers after dog
keyword well we could use these opening
and closing curly brackets and we can
say two so this means we're looking for
dog string and followed by number
exactly two times if you rerun the
script now you can say it does not match
if you reduce these two numbers there
were three file we run the code it's
going to say matches because there are
two characters which are numbers of
their dog keyword you can also extend
this by saying 2 comma or and this means
we are looking for one to four numbers
after the docky keyword so you can do
one two save this it's going to say
matches and now if we add 99 at the end
we're going to say does not match
because here we have one two three four
five number characters if you remove
this we run our script we're going to
see that this matches if I would add
many space characters I have a script
file run the script again is going to
say matches we could inverse this and
say anything that is not a space so if
we run this it's going to say does not
match and if you would replace this with
dogs again
we run the script is going to say
matches because we're looking for dog
followed by anything that's not a space
or we could also look for Strings where
we don't care about if their uppercase
all over case and in order to do that
you could use this eye modifier so let
me just quickly remove that and change
this to dog remove this nut space
character let's save this if I run the
script file it's going to say does not
match now this is because we're looking
for lowercase dog and in this variable
we have Capital dog string if we add
this I for case insensitive rerun the
script is going to say match and we can
have lowercase uppercase mixed in here
so let's say uppercase D lowercase o and
also lowercase G if you rerun this it's
going to say matches and ignore if the
characters are uppercase or lower case
you can also inverse this matching
meaning we want to check if something
does not match your pattern then we want
to enter the truthy block for example if
you said this variable contains a cat
and instead of matching it against dog
we want to say if this does not match
dog then we want to execute the logic
with prints patches so if we save the
script run it is going to say matches
now if we add or pattern as cat
save the script file rerun it it's going
to say it does not match because test
holds a string of cats and it does not
match a cat because it actually matches
a cat meaning it's going to print that
does not match now another very useful
thing what we can use are captures and
captures allow you to well capture
patterns in the string if you look at
the previous example where we added some
numbers but we didn't care what number
this is and let's say in our logic we
wanted to actually capture what numbers
followed our string and print them out
or we can do something like test compare
if this equals or pattern which is cat
add the backslash D for number Plus for
numbers being one or more times and then
we can use parentheses capture pattern
we're looking for now the patterns that
are being captured are going to get
stored in these special variables which
are dollar sign one dollar sign two
lower sign three so on and so on so what
we could do here is that if our test
matches this pattern followed by one or
more number characters want to print out
matches followed by dollar sign one
because this is or only capture in the
string if we save this we run our code
we're going to see matches followed by
one two three and this is what we're
printing out in our first capture we
could also capture more parts such as
looking for numbers and then let's say
space characters so we're going to have
cat one two three then let's add a bunch
of spaces and then we're going to add
how many faces we captured in the second
capture group if we print this out we're
going to see matches one two three and
here's our space now you can use these
regular expressions in Loops conditional
statements to capture part of the
strings process strings and do lots of
cool things with it let's look at an
example where a processing list of items
and we want to capture first two
characters of each string we're
processing so I'm going to remove this
part of the code and I'm going to
introduce a new list which is going to
hold
the items dog rat and cats now here I'm
going to use for each Loop and we know
that for each Loop goes through every
item in our list and processes into a
code block I can say my item
and I'm gonna go through each item in
the list I Define above and for each
item I'm going to match it against
two board characters at the beginning of
the string so precisely two characters
so using captures so two parentheses and
I'm going to say my capture so if you
run this code we're going to say b o or
a and CA so again with the final list
with three strings dog red cat you go
for each item in that list we're
comparing that item with this pattern
which says any word character exactly
two times at the beginning for value and
then we're printing out the pattern we
captured which in this case ends up
being d o or a and C A now another very
useful thing you can use with rejects or
Replacements Replacements basically
allows you to give a pattern you want to
match against and replace that pattern
in the given string value with something
else so let's build up one or give an
example
so I'm going to remove this m modifier
and replace this with s which indicates
that this is your placement and I'm
going to introduce another forward
learning slash which now here holds the
pattern we want to replace or match
against and what I want to do I want to
go through all the items in the list and
I want to replace them with the keyboard
replaced so I type in replaced and here
we're not going to capture anymore so
let's remove these parentheses let's
also remove the anchor tag and instead
of saying the capture because we are not
capturing anything anymore so this is
going to be on the find we're going to
say item we save this rerunner script
frequency replaced followed by g t t so
it means we went to every single item in
this list we looked for anything at the
beginning of the string which is two
World characters and we replaced it with
a literal which is replaced and then we
printed out the modified item which
resulted in these three strings replace
G replace T and replace D again because
G T and T now before we move on I just
quickly wanted to come back to the
captures and show you how you can store
every single matches against your
pattern into a list of items for example
if we wanted to compare our item to a
pattern and capture specific parts of it
in a list and store it somewhere what we
could do we could assign all the
captures to a list context because every
single time a pattern is matched the
reject is going to return all the
matches against your given pattern let's
see that in a practice so if I say my at
captures
now I want to go back to using M
keywords and instead of replacement I'm
just going to use a simple match so here
I want to capture the first character
and let's say I also want to capture the
second character so if we replace item
with dumper backslash at captures which
is going to turn this into a reference
and it's going to be nicely printed in
the console we run this oops actually we
need to compare this against something
because now we're saying all captures is
being compared against this pattern but
what we want to do we want to assign
other captures of item to our array
we rerun this we're going to see that
every single time we went through the
loop we compared for Strings and we
captured first two characters so the
first capture was stored as an item one
in the list and the second capture was
stored as an item two in the list that
goes on for all the strings in order to
find array which is called list so what
we got captured here is do for dog or a
for rat and CA or cat
so this is it for this video we looked
at how to use regular expressions in
Pearl how to capture and replace parts
of strings auto match on patterns and a
handful of special characters to help
with string matching do know that what
we looked at in this video is only the
tip of an iceberg when it comes to
regular Expressions there is so so much
more to cover and learn it simply would
be impossible to add everything in one
video and even with these Basics we
covered this video was quite long I do
hope you found this video useful and
I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will look at some very
useful built-in Pro functions that you
will most definitely be using quite
often when writing Pro code some of
these functions such as delete Keys
values push shift on shift pop Keller
and others we already saw in previous
lectures so I won't go into details on
them however and rest assured there are
plenty others worth mentioning some of
the popular ones being for example map
so what map does it basically executes a
code block for every item you give it
for example we could introduce a new
array which is called list and what it's
going to do it's actually going to
produce a new list with modified items
now if we say that my list is going to
contain the cat dog save this and we use
a function such as uppercase for UC we
can provide the current item context in
the map and the current context as we
saw before is defined by dollar sign
underscore so if we save this run our
script so Pearl script.pl nothing
happens because of course we need also
print or List which is the new list so
say dumper and then let's reference this
for easier readability and give it a new
list we run the script oops we also need
a semicolon run this again we're going
to see cat and dog so all original lists
contain lowercase cat dog we gave our
map function a block of code which says
uppercase every element you give to this
map function which is the list for two
strings and produce a new list which now
contains uppercased cat and dog now do
take note that opposite to using for
Loops if we use map function it's
actually not going to modify the items
in place if I print out the list the
original list we provided to map
function I'm going to see that it still
contains lowercase cat and dog so it
actually copies every item and returns a
new list in this case we are signing the
list of items to a new array called new
list of course we could just so modify
this further by saying my item which is
a local item uppercasing the current
context assigning it to this variable
then let's say we want to append
something to the item such as underscore
new
and then we want to return the item
you're going to see oops actually we
need to print out the new list because
there's printing out the original list
which as you can see still hasn't
changed and we're going to see cat the
uppercase version of our initial string
which we then used append string with
underscore new and then we're returning
that item now another useful function we
can use is called gray so grip is kinda
similar to map but not really what it
does it takes list as well similar to
map however instead of modifying the
item in place it's going to compare
something and if it evaluates to true
it's going to return that item to a new
list so let's see this by example so if
I replace map with grid remove all of
this code logic
and let's say I wanted to return the
item if it equals to cat so I could use
the current context dollar sign
underscore equals to cat
and basically what you provide to grip
is an expression which when it evaluates
the true is going to return that item in
a given list if it's going to evaluate
to false it's just going to drop it so
if we save this rerun our script you're
going to see cat into the normal list
this is because we went through all the
items in the list compared if this
equals to cat and if it does we're
returning it from the graph function and
it builds a new list we can also say if
this equals to cat
this being the current context or the
current context equals to dog we want to
return it we print this again now we see
cat and dog in our new list because the
first element matched from this
condition and then the second element
matched from the right hand side
condition
now another useful function you can use
is called split and what split does it
basically takes a pattern and a string
and it splits that given string based on
that pattern and returns multiple Parts
the string will split into so let's look
at example if I say my
Parts equals split keyword we are going
to give it a pattern which is going to
be let's say letter e and we're going to
give it a string which is test it's also
extended with another test for this to
become clearer we save this and we run
our script oops of course we also want
to print this out so if it says say
dumper and part save this run the code
you're going to see these parts which is
t s t underscore T and St so why is that
well this is because we're saying all
pattern we want to split on is the e but
we don't want to preserve the E we just
want to split on it so basically our
string becomes B part one then the part
2 is St followed by T up until the
second D then the last part which is St
or string got split into three parts but
a given pattern letter e now you can
also do cool things such as for example
if you give no pattern whatsoever what's
going to happen is that your string is
actually going to get split on every
single character and sometimes this can
be quite useful if you want reverse
strings modify them in particular way or
any other scenario but it's just good to
know if you don't give it a pattern but
the split function it's just going to
split on every single letter in that
string
now the next function we're going to
look at is called join and join is
opposite to the split so instead of
splitting a string into into multiple
patterns it's going to actually join a
list of strings into a single string so
let's say that we want to redefine all
parts which is going to be both words a
b c d e
we saved this and instead of the parts
we're going to say
all
string
equals or join keyboard followed by
string what we want to join on so let's
say underscore and followed by the list
so if you replace Parts with full string
and we run our code oops actually it's
not called list anymore it's called
parts so this again we run the code is
going to be a b c d e join with
underscore of course you can just apply
empty string and rerun this again and
that's just going to be ABCD joined all
together as some other useful functions
or you see or uppercase that we saw
before but we can also use LC for
lowercase and we can uppercase First
characters or lowercase first character
let's see an example so if I can have my
test equals
cats and I want to say that my cat
equals you see uppercase test replace
full string with the test variable save
this run the code it's going to be
uppercase cat and we already saw this
before this is nothing new to us
however we can also uppercase the cat
and we can use LC for lowercase if we
print this out again instead of printing
out uppercase cat is going to print
lowercase version of the cat because
we're running through this LC function
now we can also use LC first if we rerun
this we're going to see that it's
lowercasing the first character
everything else is still uppercase if
you reverse this and we have a string
which is cat and we say you see first
oops you see first we run our script and
as you might have guessed it instead of
the first character being lowercase it's
actually going to be the first character
uppercase now what if we wanted to find
the length of a string well we can use
this keyword called length so if I
assign this to my size
and remove this part and if we print out
size
we're going to see three so what the
length does it counts the characters in
your string so or string consists of
three characters cat so it prints out
three if you say cats and
dogs
they have this we run the code is going
to be 11 characters now we can also use
a function such as Rand which is going
to give us a random number and a given
number to the function for example if I
say rent
and give it a number of 10.
if I save this rerun the code oops looks
like we're still printing size but we
want to print the test variable if I
rerun the code is going to give a
decimal number and this is where another
function could actually become handy so
if you wanted to convert a number
without decimal places to an integer you
can use function called int
if we wrap our random function given 10
with in function and rerun our code
you're going to get six so thing to note
is that for example if I give it a
number such as 4.5 it's going to give us
4. if I would give a number such as 4.6
it's still going to give us 4 because
what in does that doesn't give the floor
meaning the lowercase version after the
small points or the upper case it just
removes the second part of a decimal
number so even if you have something
like 4.9999 if you save this rerun it
it's still going to be or some more
interesting functions is you can use
keywords such as sleep so sleep is going
to stop the execution of your code for
the given amount of seconds so if I say
sleep 2 for 2 seconds and then I want to
print something like I walk up
and save this and run our code to run it
nothing happens nothing happens and boom
we got I woke up printed to our console
so sleep helps the execution of our code
for the given amount of seconds now
going back to Strings we can also get
substrings of the given value for
example if I say my value equals
substring with sub SDR
and then I give a string such as cat
and value 0 and 1. save this and then we
say the value
then the codes run it
going to give a letter C you can see
here so what this does the substring
basically takes a string it takes the
index of that string and how many
characters at that index you want to
capture afterwards so if I said one as
the middle number and two as the last
number and run the script again is going
to print out at and this is because
we're looking at index 1 which is a and
then after that specified index is going
to take two characters which is a t and
that is exactly what we're seeing
printed out in a console or you might
also be interested in Epoch time and to
retrieve that value you could let's say
say time so we're basically calling say
function value of time function we run
this we're going to see the second
selects in Epoch time if we run this we
see this was seven seconds ago and so on
so this is it for this video we looked
at some of the more popular functions
used in Pro this list is nowhere near
complete make sure to check the lecture
notes with reference to resources where
you can find more information the
functions we looked at and plenty others
I hope you found this video useful and I
will see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will look at some of the
special reserved Pro variables and how
you can use them we already use some of
these variables before such as regular
expression capture placeholders using
the dollar sign 1 dollar sign 2 Etc and
the current context variable written as
dollar sign underscore however there are
many more to explore so let's look at
some other variables now one of these
variables is called arc V for argument
values and as you can see this is array
and what this value is going to hold are
the current arguments passed to your
script through command line so let's
print it out now as it is by referencing
the argument values and if we run our
script we're going to see that this is
an empty list now if we rerun our script
with variables such as 1 a b or 2.
you're going to see that our list which
is the argument values now holds 1 a b
and 2 that are the arguments in the
exact order we pass to the script and
you can use the argual exactly as you
would use the list so if you wanted to
access the first item in the list you
would use dollar sign
ARG V and access the first value in the
list so what we can see now printed in a
console is one because this is a list
where accessing the first element and it
holds a value of one now another useful
thing you might find is using these two
dollar signs and what it holds is the
actual process ID of the script so every
single time you run a process on your
system you get to sign the process ID so
if you're doing some C submit tasks or
you want to see if your script is
running you can always check the
processor day now how we can know that
this process ID is actually true what
was printed let's introduce a infinite
Loop so if I say while
one do nothing if I run the script it's
going to print the number 9077 which is
the current process ID
and if I open up a new terminal
I could check the current running
processes and how to do that you can
type PS aux and you can grab for
specific pattern which in this case
would be or script name script.pl
then we're going to see that our script
is currently running with process ID
9077 this is the exact ID we got printed
out in the previous terminal window and
we see actually two entries here and
this is because the second entry was our
grep statement the first process is the
one where we actually have the infinite
Loop running I have gone back to my
first terminal and I have quit the
script that are running infinite Loop
before so we're basically back in the
previous state where we were now the
next variable we're going to look at or
sign closing square bracket if I remove
this infinite Loop and if you already
run the script we are going to see this
number
5.036000 and you might be wondering what
it is and this is actually the pro
version that is executing this script if
I say pro version to see which version
we're currently using is going to be
5.36.0 so it might be useful in some
scenarios let's explore this array
called Inc
for includes if I print this out in the
terminal I'm going to see a couple of
things currently in this array and what
is Inc that stands for includes olds is
the actual paths to modules and current
pro version core modules that we can use
in our code and this can become
extremely useful and we're going to see
some scenarios in future where we can
modify this includes array for example
if we have modules in a different
directory we can push New Paths to this
include array and pro is going to find
them but for now just know that it holds
absolute Paths of directories where Pro
can find modules now the next variable
we're going to look at is called EnV and
this is not a list this is actually a
hash so it's written as capital EnV and
it stands for environment variables if
you run our scripts we're going to see
our default system variable such as what
is the home directory is right here and
the current language and so on and so on
and this is quite useful if if you want
to run your script with specific
environment variables such as you could
do test
EnV VAR equals one and instead of
printing just all the environment
variables we could just print this one
item in the hash
is going to be the test dnv bar
save this run our script we're going to
see that War equals to one maybe let's
just add something more useful for
example custom string
save this and here we see that this
environment variable was picked up by
the script the next variable we're going
to look at is this standard input so the
standard input is basically just taking
the input from your script and we did
see it briefly when we were looking at
how to run Pearl through command line so
if we repeat this through while loop and
we use this diamond operator
and we explicitly say that we want to
take the standard inputs
and what we're going to do we're just
going to print out the current context
which is again accessed by dollar sign
underscore if we save this run our
scripts maybe let's run it without
environment variable
so let's run it again and let's say we
want to do hello
and here we go so we wrote hello and
then we just got the standard input and
we printed out hello again and as you
saw before we can do modifications on
this input which is uppercasing it
lowercasing it's splitting it up in
characters so on and so on so let's quit
this for now and let's shoot the next
variable which is called underscore
underscore file and to following
underscores if we save this run our code
is going to print out script so what the
file holds is the name of our script
file which in this case is script.pl you
can also use something like underscore
underscore online to underscores again
this and we're gonna see 10. because we
are currently on a line 10 and another
one called package
if we save this run our script and it's
going to give us the main package not
very useful for now but just know that
the main package is the current script
you're working in when we're going to be
looking at modules this is going to
become much more useful because when
this variable references or actual
package name since we don't have any
package no Pro module it reference our
script which is the current main package
so this is it for this video we looked
at some of the pro special variables and
how you can use them in your scripts as
with built-in functions this list is
nowhere complete my suggestion is don't
try to memorize all of these special
variables most likely you will only use
a very small subset of them anyway you
can always refer to the documentation to
find what you're looking for I hope you
found this video useful and I'll see you
at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture
it's time to bring out the big guns and
talk about object oriented programming
in Pearl in this video we will explore
what are classes objects attributes and
methods and how you approach
object-oriented programming in Pro note
we will be exploring the built-in Pros
object-oriented system out of the box in
this video however later in this course
we will use a module called Mouse to
create an interact with object the mouse
module will allow us to build much
better object oriented code where we can
introduce attribute types validations
and other great features that are not
provided by press default object
oriented programming approach let's get
started first of all what is object
oriented programming well it's a concept
that is based on structuring your data
and logic in objects each object has
properties and methods defined by their
classes but the attribute values and
results produced by these methods are
specific to each object for example you
can define a dog class and we know that
dogs have specific breed Heights way 8
color name and other similar properties
you can view these as attributes of a
dog class you can create an object of a
dog class and set attributes such as
breed equals Labrador Heights equals 60
centimeters weight 50 kilograms color
golden name Fido so on and so on this
specific dog Fido now would become an
object of a class dog you can add
methods to your class such as get
average speed where you calculate the
running speed of Fido using height and
weight it might be a silly method to
have but hopefully it explains of how
each method would produce different
results for each object of the dog class
if all of this sounds confusing no
worries it's a tricky concept to grasp
at first but it becomes so much easier
the more you practice object oriented
programming now let's look at an example
what we discussed being used in Pro now
let's start by creating a new file and
we're gonna call it dog as we discussed
before instead of using PL extension for
pro script we're going to use dot PM or
Pro module we're going to write the
package name which is dog so technically
module files are not meant to be
executable so we don't need to provide
our system with indication of how this
file should be run because you don't
really execute the module files directly
and as with scripts it's good to return
a truthy value and it's especially
required for modules because you need to
tell the use directive as we saw before
and also this required director which
you're going to look in next lectures
the compilation of this class succeeded
and if you don't have this truthy value
in Pro module files your compiler is
going to complain now the next thing
we're going to use is strict
frogmas and use warning progress because
we still want to write better and less
error print code now afterwards what
we're going to do we're going to
introduce a method which is called New
now this method is going to receive the
first argument as a class and this first
argument is going to refer to the
current package name so before the
package names were not that useful when
we were working with script files but
now since we are working with modules
this is going to become much more useful
and in that matter necessary because we
will want to initialize instances of
these classes with this package name now
let's add some attributes we talked
about before for example breed
fights
weights
color
and name
and we're going to get all of this from
this argument variable we looked at
before so basically this is an array
that is going to hold all of these
arguments as to the new function and the
class package name which is basically
dog in this case is going to be
automatically given by the pro module
file so let's remove that and the next
thing you want to do you want to
initialize self and self is just going
to be a hashref so it's going to hold a
couple of key value pairs these key
value pairs are going to be attributes
that we are passing to our class at the
time when we want to initialize any
object so for example we want to set the
breed to be the breed
byte to be
bytes
wait to be
wait
color to be color
and name to hold a value of name that we
are going to be passing to this instance
of classdog now the next thing we want
to do we want to bless our instance it's
keyword bless by providing self which is
the hash ref and the class which is the
last name being dog now basically a
place is going to do some inner magic
but you can look at this as that objects
in probe are glorified hashrefs that
have a name assigned to it class name
that says that this hash F belongs to
this class which in this case is going
to be dog and afterwards we want to
return self
we're done with constructing and setting
the attributes of this class let's see
how we can use this new package we just
created let's go back to our script file
and let's try to use it with the same
use statement we did for data dumper
let's try to pull into dot class
if we save this and now if we try to run
our script it's going to complain it's
going to say that looks like I can't
find this dog PM in includes and we
looked at this includes Global variable
before this is where this Global
attribute becomes useful because now you
can specify additional paths where Pearl
can find this module so for example and
we didn't look at this keyword before
we're gonna use begin and begin block is
basically just telling that this
execution of code has to be done with
the before these use statements and
again we're going to look into how use
actually works behind the scenes but
just know that when you are saying use a
module it's actually running begin block
as well and putting it at the start of
your script so if we try to push
something on includes array now this
would actually get done after we're
requiring our modules so with begin
block we're saying that we want this
logic where we're adding New Paths to
the includes to be done before we are
requiring this dog module so I could do
something like add Inc which is the
includes and here we can provide the
absolute path of the directory where
this module can be found and we can try
to discover the current absolute path
using our current working directory or
modules but I'm just going to give it an
absolute path of the folder we're
currently working from so if I push this
to the includes
save the file
run it again it's not going to complain
because now Pearl knows from the
includes variable where we can find this
dog now if I would remove this begin
block and just try to push something on
the ink
is going to complain and this is what I
talked about before because view
statements are just using begin blocks
behind the scenes so requiring of this
module actually gets executed before
we're pushing on to this includes array
now that's one way how to use a module
an alternative is to specify additional
libraries where you can find modules
through command line in this case we
could say roll minus I for includes and
dots for the current directory if we run
this the script is not going to complain
and if I remove the includes path it's
going to complain again and I'm going to
go with a letter approach because it's
just easier and we don't need to add
extra boilerplate and we know how to
create classes and set the expected
attributes and we also looked at how we
can provide paths to tell Pearl where to
find or modules now let's look at how we
can get an instance of this class now to
get an instance of this class you can
say my dollar sign and dog
and this is just going to be scalar this
is going to hold a reference of the dog
instance and to initialize a new dog
instance we can say dog or package name
and new and this is this method we
created in our package file AKA class
file
and we can see that it accepts couple of
attributes so I'm going to just copy
them over place them here so we keep the
correct order and set them by providing
these arguments in the new method so I'm
going to say that the breed is Labrador
the height is 50. let's say weight is 70
we're going to have a chunky Labrador
color I'm gonna say that it's golden and
for name I'm gonna say Fido and save
this if you run our code that looks good
there's no complaints but nothing
happens nothing happens because we're
not really calling any methods or we're
not accessing the attributes so let's
change that now press object oriented
approach out of the box doesn't really
come with accessors Getters and Setters
and the Getters are pretty much saying
give me the value of an attribute on
this instance and Setter would do the
opposite it would say set a new
attribute value for this instance so
let's add some Getters first and Getters
are nothing more dangerous subroutines
AKA functions so we could do SUB let's
call it a breed for the function
decoration I'm going to say my
itself
equals shift so we haven't seen shift
working or nothing before but basically
when you're working on Pro you're always
getting the current context when you're
calling a method so in this case we
could also write shift the current
argument list but in practice you're
going to see that usually it's just the
shift keyword now self is something new
it's not the class anymore self is
actually going to be the Blessed version
of the class AKA is going to be a
hashrift that holds key value pairs of
these values so what we could do
we could return self an access key
called breed now if we go back to our
script file and here we print something
like dog
read
save this
run our file is going to say Labrador
you might be wondering but hey can I not
access it simply as a key on my dog
instance such as read
and if we run this yes yes you actually
can but that's not a good practice
because you're actually accessing
internals of that instance the proper
way how you work with attributes setting
and getting them is through the setter
and getter methods which we just have
introduced here because the attribute
names can also change or you want to add
new logic later on and it's good to
encapsulate your Getters and Setters in
case you want to extend the logic all
the attribute name changes so you don't
have to go in every single place in your
codes and change the value of that key
which is the current cell blessed
reference now let's quickly add another
attribute getter for example fights and
I'm just going to return
right here if we save this go back to
Scripts and we're going to say height
just to say that it's working as
expected and it does it prints out 50 to
the console now what about Setters well
there's really nothing magical to it so
the same as the Getters their functions
where you are modifying the currently
blessed self-reference by overwriting
the value so you could say something
like sub
sit fight
and here we could expect to receive two
attributes yourself and the new height
and we're gonna get that from the
argument list and what we're going to do
we're going to access self byte
I'm going to set it to height and you
might be wondering well didn't you just
say it's not good to access internals by
using keys on these hashrefs which are
blast cells uh yes it's it's a bad
practice to do that but as long as
you're doing it outside of the actual
class so here we're defining these
methods and attributes inside a class
and we're modifying them on the instance
so as long as we are not doing it
outside of our class this is perfectly
fine so now if I go back to the script
file and before I'm printing out the
Heights I'm going to say dog byte equals
70.
so note that we originally set it to 50.
maybe I'm going to choose a different
number because we're using 70 for weight
I'm going to say 120 and save this run
the code and we're still getting 50 and
that's because we are actually calling
the getter method so we want to set the
height if we rerun this we're going to
see 120. now what about methods well
again it's nothing really magical about
them you just introduce a new subroutine
AKA function so we can add something
like sub
get byte
and wait
and again we're going to get self as the
first argument we're going to shift it
off from the argument list and what
we're going to return is going to be
self
height
plus self
weight
we save that go back to script and let's
remove the setting over height and let's
just do this function name which is get
height and get weight so if I call this
which is sit
bytes and
wait
apologies is not set but it's actually
get save this run the script is going to
return 120 because 50 for the height and
70 for the weight equals 120 I could
change the height to 100 save this again
rerun that script and it's going to be
170. now another useful thing you can
use in your classes is this default
method called destroy and you write it
with capital letters destroy
and here we're just going to print
something out like print by everyone
exclamation mark new line and save this
if we rerun or script
is going to print out 170 from this
method and then it's going to say bye
everyone and the destroy method is
basically useful for if you want to do
any cleaning up in your instances before
they get picked up by the garbage
collector for example if you wanted to
do some logging or reach out to a server
or anything whatsoever based on
different use cases you can do that in
Destroy method so object oriented
programming is quite useful because you
can initialize different instances of a
class so if I have doc2
and I'm going to say that this is
or maybe 20
or color something else that doesn't say
just color so white
and the name Bob poodle called Bob we're
gonna have a different isolated Logic
for instance of a class so now if I say
dog 2 which is going to get the height
plus weight and I'm actually going to
concatenate it with dog I'm going to be
cheeky here and I'm just going to access
the key on the instance which is the
name because we didn't introduce the
setter method but don't do that a bit of
spacing concatenate this and the same
for dog2
and let's change that to dog 2 because
that Source variable name save this run
the code we're going to see two separate
calculations so for Fido which is the
first print statement we get 170 so
these values summed up and for doc2
which is named Bob we're gonna get value
30 which is these two values summed up
and you're also going to notice that
destroy methods run individually for
each of these instances just to quickly
mention you could also be passing in
named arguments as you looked at the
functions where we were using subroutine
signatures or you can pass in hash or a
hash ref instead of arguments in a list
it's really your choice
so this is it for this video in this
lecture we looked at what is object
oriented programming and how we can
create objects using Pros default after
the Box object oriented system note that
we did not touch on inheritance and
using roles to compose our classes in
case you have heard of these terms these
are a bit more advanced concepts that we
will be looking in the future lessons
when building classes with mouse and
we'll explore those Concepts in more
detail there I hope you found this video
useful and I will see you at the next
one
other and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will look at the
difference between require keyword and
use keyword in Pearl to load modules in
your code now the very basic key
difference between use and require
statements are that require is for
requiring a module at a runtime and use
statement is for using a module at
compile time let me quickly demonstrate
let's try to use a module that does not
exist for example I do not exist and
hopefully you haven't installed module
with such name otherwise this will work
but I will trust that you haven't if I
save this file run the script you're
going to see that I do not exist in
includes path and we looked at the
includes before and we know that these
are all the paths where Pearl can look
for the modules and if it finds it it's
going to include it in our codes and all
is going to be well however in this
scenario we don't have such module so
it's going to break all the time now
let's introduce a logical statement for
example if I say if
one is larger than 2 only then I want to
use this module
if I move it down here save the code and
run the script again it's going to
complain again and this is because even
though we're using this use statement
The Logical expression
we have to remember that U statements
are always executed in these begin
blocks that we looked at before meaning
these begin blocks are going to run
before any other logic at compile time
and as I mentioned before the use
statement is nothing more than a
shortcut or requiring a module which
would be I do not exist now talking
about requiring let's remove the begin
block and let's change this to
require I do not exist let's rerun our
code and this works you might be
thinking well maybe this required
actually doesn't do anything and I'm
just talking nonsense however if I do
remove this if statement and rerun the
code
you're going to see that or I'll try to
find this module in our include pads and
it couldn't now this brings back to the
key difference I talked about so use is
always going to be executed at compile
time via the begin block and require is
going to be executed in runtime so you
can acquire modules conditionally or you
might be wondering why you would prefer
using require overuse and vice versa
well it depends most of the time you
will most likely want to go with the use
statement if you know beforehand that
the module being loaded definitely will
be needed in your code however for
example there can be times where you
work with data you want to do extra
processing on values conditionally if
that extra processing logic is isolated
in a module and you don't know if you'll
need it then you can require a module
during runtime to pull in the necessary
code as we did with the example before
where we said if a condition passes we
want to require a module which in this
case does not exist let's look at other
key points the burning question probably
is how does this all work behind scenes
well it's nothing really magical as we
saw before Pearl has this ink array
which stands for includes and holds a
list of paths or Pro confined modules
now when you use a module for example
data dumper as we have been using it
before or Pro is going to do it's going
to convert the two columns to the path
name and append the PM file so basically
use data dumper becomes data
forward slash dumper dot PM which then
is being looked at ink folder where all
the paths in there going to look for
base path and it's going to append the
module name which is the data dumper
and try to load it from there so if we
explore some of these paths such as here
and we have couple of paths so hopefully
the module we're looking for is going to
be in the first one if I do LS on this
path and if I look here for data jumper
well data looks like it's not here let's
check the directory before is this one
if it LS this and try to go into Data
here we go we see data dumper.pm Pro
retrieves the logic of this file from
this path which is the lib 5.36 the
current Pro version we're using or
higher depends when you're watching this
video and then one further path up and
then the data folder and then the dumper
PM we saw that this path was in our
includes folder which is this and the
data dumper was simply appended to it
don't feed bisect this even further I
did mention before as well that when you
use the use keyword what happens is
behind the scenes Pearl is actually
calling require parsing the module name
as data forward Linux slash or depends
on your system ending with that PM so in
the end it would look something like
this another key difference is that when
you use the use statement it's going to
call the module name
which is data dumper and import which is
going to get a list of method names you
want to import from that module or if no
method names are provided it's just
going to export everything by default
let's see an example I just comment this
out for the time being and I do use data
dumper
and I'm going to print out a dumper
and just a string test save this
run the script
and as expected we're seeing the test
string now if I change this to require
we should technically still work
rerun the code it's actually going to
complain that Pearl could not find the
method dumper in the current main
package and we know that the main
package is referring to the script so
basically there is no dumper method
defined in the current package so this
is where this import method comes into
play the require by default does not
import all the default exported methods
and going back to the use statement and
the input functionality you could also
explicitly specify that you want to
import dumper method if you rerun this
we're going to see that this works as
well and vice versa you could actually
provide an empty list and say that you
don't want to import anything if we
rerun the code it's going to complain
again that downpour method could not be
found so that's another key difference
when you're using a use statement just
remember that it's always going to get
executed at compile time through this
begin block and it's going to convert
the module name with the column colon to
the path based on the system and it's
going to require that module and
additionally it's going to import all
the default important methods unless as
you looked at here you explicitly
specify the methods you want to import
from that module but here we are not
importing anything at all and we're
trying to use a method that actually
does exist in data dumper but it's not
being imported or if I try to import
something like does not exist
so the file we run it it's just going to
say that does not exist is not exported
by the data dumper module and this is
quite handy for example if you only want
to work with specific methods from
modules and you don't want to import
everything that the module offers or
even further if you want to use the
fully qualified module name to color
method such as this
so here it might be confusing because
the method is also called dumper but all
that's happening is that we're saying
that we want to use from this package
data dumper a method called dumper even
though we're not importing it explicitly
you can still use it by referring to
this module and to come back to this
conversion from colon to path separators
you could change this to require
beta replace this with forward leaning
slash
add.pm at the end
and try to call this method again oops
with a red semicolon let's save this we
run it again and it works so here you
can see that we are importing a module
based on the path not the package name
now the required is also quite handy if
you want to import other scripts because
by default you can't use scripts in
other scripts through use command let's
look at this so if I remove all of this
boilerplate and I'm going to introduce a
new file and I'm going to call this
script2.pl now let's set the sheet Bank
line so user pin environment Pearl use
strict use warnings and it's a good
practice to always write this out let's
add a truth a value at the end the
indicate to the pro compiler the
requiring of the script file succeeded
otherwise we're going to get complaints
let's add a method such as sub hello
from
script to and all this is going to do is
going to print here with new line we
save this we go back to the scripts 1
and we try to use this group 2 the pl
as I mentioned before this is not going
to work so it says there's a syntax
error this could not even be parsed
however if I replace this with require I
have the file rerun it there are no
complaints so now I can call the method
which was hello from script 2.
there the file
re-run the script oops and we forgot the
extension so script.pl and we're going
to see hey up printed to the console so
this is it for this video we looked at
core differences between loading your
modules using required and use keywords
all loading modules and scripts work in
Pro and when you would opt in for one or
the other module loading method I hope
you found this video useful and I will
see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
previous video we looked at what's the
difference between using required and
use keywords we also looked at how we
can import default exported methods from
modules or we can explicitly Define
which methods we want to import such as
the dumper method on the data dumper
module now in this video we're going to
explore how we can actually build our
own methods we want to export from all
modules we're also going to look into
what's the difference between Class
method and a static method let's get
started now let's introduce a new file
and to be precise this is going to be a
pro module file and we're going to name
it all module and that PM for pro module
and then this file we want to declare
the package name which is our module we
also want to return the truth a value we
want to use strict and we want to use
warnings which is always good practice
to do and we also want to introduce a
method and let's say this method is
going to be called add nums
which is going to take two numbers
let's say num 1 and num2 and we're going
to get them from our argument list and
what we're going to return is num 1 plus
num2 now let's save our module file
let's go back to the script file and
let's try to use or module now let's run
the script file let's Provide Capital I
flag for including module paths which is
going to be our current directory noted
by dot orleaning slash and then we're
going to run our script file so we need
to save it and if we run this all looks
good now let's say we want to call this
function called add nums so I'm going to
invoke the method add nums I'm going to
give two numbers three and two and I'm
also going to print it out to the
console if we go back and try to run our
script file it's going to complain that
adms subroutine is undefined and that is
true because currently we're not
importing anything from all module and
this function add nums is not defined in
this script file so Pearl simply doesn't
know what we're trying to do when we say
add nums let's go back to our module
file and let's use this module called
exporter that we haven't used before so
use exporter
and we're going to also import the
import method from the exporter
now if you remember from the videos
before when you're calling use two
things happen Pearl is parsing your
module Name by appending the pm at the
end of it the import logic from that
module and it's also calling this import
method import all default exported
methods so here we're requiring import
method from exporter which will be
called on our module to export all the
default exported methods so how you
define which methods you want to export
is by using keyword or then this array
called export where you provide a list
of methods you want to export so add
nums in our case if we save this go back
to our terminal run the script file as
you can see number five is printed out
to the console and this is because now
when we're calling the ad nums from our
script file this method is imported by
default from or module as before if we
said we don't want to import anything
from our module rerun the script
is going to complain about not being
able to find a function at nums where in
order to call this explicitly we need to
provide a full qualified package name
such as r
module colon colon add nums and if we
run this this is working again so this
is how you can export methods from your
module file now one thing you're going
to notice is that previously when we
were building our classes and instance
of the classes we got this class keyword
which is not the case now nor adnumbs
function and this is because we're not
initializing a new instance of this
module we're simply using adnumbs
function using these two columns so this
is called a static method the key
takeaway here is that when you're using
static methods you're not getting the
class name automatically provided as the
first argument however if we would be
needing the class variable in our
function we could call it with arrow
notation if we say discrete file and go
back to the module just print it out so
let's print out the class let's open the
new line save the module file we run the
script we're going to see two things all
module printed out and then the number
five so this was the first print
statement where we automatically got the
class name and in our script file after
printing this method at nums which adds
two numbers so this is the difference
between instance methods class method
and static method the instance method is
called by initializing a new instance
from a class where you're getting the
self context the given attributes also
the class name and Etc and it's being
invoked by this error function of course
in this scenario we are not actually
building the attributes in the self and
we are not also blessing the self hash
ref with the package name however we're
still getting the class name as the
first argument since we are invoking it
with a narrow function and that's why
it's called the class method now the
final method which we called initially
was with these two columns we would save
this we run the script which you're
going to observe here is that actually
number three was printed out and then a
warning about that we're trying to use
uninitialized num2 in addition in all
module but what happened now is that the
first two arguments which are class and
non-one are taken directly from our
script file as the arguments we passed
here so we're never getting the 2 as the
third argument and instead we end up
printing out a class name and trying to
add num1 variable which would hold
number two in this case and then adding
number two variable which currently is
undefined now to quickly go back on the
export methods alternative of using this
at export array you could use export
underscore OK and if we remove this
class name
and print class name and just return the
sum of two numbers we go back to our
script and let's also remove the package
name and save this file run it through
terminal we're going to see that ad
num's function wasn't defined actually
we also need to remove the foldboard for
explicitly not importing it save this
rerun it again and we're still seeing
that warning and the difference here is
when you're using export as we did
initially without the underscore okay
all the methods in that array are going
to be exported by default when you're
using underscore okay appended to export
these methods are not automatically
imported meaning you need to explicitly
import those methods you're exporting
from your modules if I save this we run
the code it works again so this is it
for this video looked at how to use
exporter what's the difference between
export and Export OK and we also took a
step back and we looked at what our
instance methods class methods and
static methods now when you use each is
really up to you and the use Case by the
end of the day really depends on
scenarios what you're trying to achieve
sometimes you just want to encapsulate
the logic which does a very simple thing
such as adds to numbers in that case you
don't really want to initialize a new
instance of an object and you can simply
use a static or a class method to do
anything that doesn't require a
self-context now when you need a
self-context to access attributes that
have been initialized by creating an
instance of a class then you would use
an instance method and access the
current self-context but again it's
really up to a use case and it's up to
you when to use the different accessors
at different times I hope you found this
video useful and I'll see you at the
next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will look into how we can
install Pro modules using CPM AKA C pen
minus the pearls package slash module
manager before we begin I would like to
know that Pearl actually already comes
with package manager called cpan that is
without an m at the end so this begs a
question why would we be using something
that's called cpan M instead of the
default package manager well think of
cpan and cpan M being exactly the same
they both are needed to install and
manage Pearl modules however the cpan M
requires no configuration and is much
less noisy in comparison to cpan when
installing modules also it is incredibly
easy and quick to install cpan M when
using Pro Brew so there's really no
reason why not to get it on your system
now to install cpan on your system you
want to go to your terminal and you want
to type problem
blue
and what are you going to get is bunch
of commands related to the pro Brew
Pearl and so on what you're interested
in this case is a command that says
install cpanem so let's run this so if I
copy this command and type problem
followed by install cpnm and run this
it's literally going to take a split
second for cpnm to be installed in your
system or you can verify that this is
running you can do which cpnm and this
is going to give you the absolute path
to the cpan binary and that's it easy as
that we now have cpan M on our system
which is going to be automatically
initialized on the new sessions we are
now ready to install some Pro modules
how you can install modules is by typing
cpun minus minus help you get a manual
page and here we can see to install
module you can simply run cpnm and the
module name which is going to install
module in our system now there are other
options you might want to run your
installation with which is this verbose
option that kind of tells you more
information of what's going on when
you're installing a module you can also
Force install modules guys there are
some dependency issues but you're fairly
certain the module is going to work
anyway and usually even modules are
being installed they're also run tests
and you can specify a flag not to run
those tests you can also install modules
from a file which is quite handy because
you can keep track of all your modules
in a file and then run CPA name
installed apps and provide a c pen file
which has all the modules that needs to
be installed and there are others to
explore but we will focus on the simple
command which is cpan and the module
name to install a specific module the
official Pro module repository is
located at matisseapan.org so let's go
there that's why searching Google meta
cpan
I'm going to see this link
which is metcpen.org we go there you're
going to notice that it's quite
minimalistic and it's straight to the
business so let's say you're met with a
single search bar and you can use this
to browse the massive module ecosystem
let's say I wanted to find a module that
can help me with converting between Json
string to hashrav structure and vice
versa so what I could do I could search
for Json
and on what I'm going to see here are a
couple of options presented to me it
might be overwhelming at times and you
might not know which module to pick but
most times you can simply choose a
module which is at the top of the list
and if you want to find more information
about that module you can of course
browse the name of it see how much is
being used to understand if it's the
best fit for the job now if I select the
Json access I'm going to be taken to the
documentation and usually the module
documentation on matte cpan is excellent
it gives you some examples of how to run
this module General description any
pitfalls so on and so on it's always
good practice to read the documentation
to understand if the module you're
looking at is actually suited for the
job in this case at the top of the page
I can see those two things it encodes a
Json and supposedly it provides a Json
text and it also decodes a Json text and
provides a hash ref or array ref all
depends on a Json structure but at this
point I'm fairly certain that this is
what I need now to install the module
let's copy the name
let's go back to the terminal and simply
run CPA name and then the module name
which is Json Holden colon Xs
so I run this this is going to take a
couple of seconds to install and that's
it it shows that the module has been
installed on our system well to be more
precise it's installed into location
where the probe room manages all the
modules installed for the current Pro
version we're using through the pro Brew
so again this is why the problem is
quite useful because it keeps the things
isolated from each other now if you go
to our editor and let's say we want to
use this module how you do that is by
using this use keyword that we explored
before and then the module name which is
Json colon colon Xs and we can save the
file
if we run this with pearl script nothing
happens this is because we are using the
module we're not getting any complaints
that this module could not be found but
we're also not using any functions from
this module so let's go back to the
documentation
and here we can see that we can call
encode Json which we don't need to
explicitly import from Json XS so I copy
this name
go back to the script let's try to print
out a hashf that is a value Json
structure for example if I print
dumper
and I'm going to wrap around the anchor
Json function
and in this angle Json I'm going to
provide anonymous hashref
I'm going to end this with semicolon and
let's say I want to encode a key which
holds value 1 and b key which was the
value of 2. if I save this from the
script and here we go we can see that
this is a string printed or terminal
with two keys B value 2 and key a with
value one now the documentation also
states that we can decode Json so let's
try that if I copy this method name
go back to the editor and instead of
encoding a Json
I'm going to use
deco.json now here what we can do we can
copy the string which we encoded before
and provide that instead of a hash of
structure we save this run our script
it's going to convert from a Json string
into a hashrift structure so by now you
probably have noticed that array refs
and hash refs are quite similar with the
structure of what is considered the
value Json so if I wanted to decode for
example there's an array that holds a
simple string a
save this go to the console you're going
to see that this is converted into array
ref with a single value of a so it's
quite easy by nature to convert between
protein structures and Json structure
now you're probably wondering how can
you find installed modules on your
system strangely there is no
straightforward way to do it one of the
options is to use another module which
is called EXT utils installed and this
module is going to give a list of
modules currently installed on our
system so if I go to the documentation
and look for EXT utils colon colon
installed
which is the second option
copy the module name
go back to the terminal and if I say
cpnm install this module we're actually
going to see that this is one of the
core modules so you don't even need to
install it so if I go to my editor and
use this module by EXT utils column call
installed it has a method which is
called modules that we need to call on a
new instance of this EXT utils and it's
going to return a list of module names
so what we could do we could print
dumper
and it's the dumper function you could
say EXT utils installed
new so we're initializing a new instance
of this class and we chain our methods
on this new instance called modules if I
save that go to the terminal run the
script here we go we see a couple of
installed modules in our system in order
that we don't see stuff like exporter
that we looked at before our data dumper
and this is because this module does not
list the core modules of pro it only
lists the ones that we have installed on
the side it's still quite handy utility
to know what's installed on your current
Pro module path this is it for this
video we hope that where to find and
install Pro modules I hope you found
this video useful and I'll see you at
the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore a better way
of handling exceptions in Perl using two
modules try tiny smart catch and
exception class instead of using evolve
and die functions as we saw before first
of all why would we want to use modules
to handle exceptions instead of using
the good old baked in error handling a
pro well some very valid reasons would
be that maybe you would like to execute
some additional logic in your code when
a node exception was drawn or you might
want to log exceptions with different
priority based on exception type for
example if a user enters invalid
password when logging into your app you
might want to throw invalid password
exception and of course there's plenty
other scenarios using die and evil and
maybe some rejects could achieve this
organization of error layers but trust
me that would be a huge mess real quick
and by the end of the day we don't have
to do it because we have some very
awesome tools at our disposal as I
mentioned before the first module is
called try tiny smart catch and it
basically allows you to catch errors in
different blocks by package name rejects
exact errors and handle unknown
exceptions the second module is
exception class this module allows you
to create custom named exception objects
with attributes and other goodies that
massively allows you to enhance the
management of Errors let's start by
installing these modules
now the first thing you want to do you
want to go to meta C pen and what you
want to search for is try
tiny
smart catch
so if you open it up you're going to be
presented with quite detailed
documentation and I highly suggest you
to read through it to understand bits
and pieces that maybe we will not touch
on this lecture and that stands for
every module if you don't understand
something or you would like to try
additional functionality it is highly
encouraged to check the documentation
for the time being let's copy this name
try it on a smart catch and let's go to
our terminal now I'm going to use my
editor's term now to install this module
the CPA name
and the module name and it was pretty
quick to install now the next module
that I mentioned was exception class and
it's written as exception colon colon
class so here it is in first suggestions
again as before you can check the
documentation if you want to find out
more but for time being let's just copy
the module name let's go back to our
terminal and let's install it as well
this is going to take a second or two to
get installed and I'll see you once it's
done now the modules are done installing
and we are ready to use them in our code
however before we proceed I'd like to
have a quick refresher on how we Throw
and handle errors in Pro so if you
remember we used this keyword called die
Then followed by message for example I
can type this is it
if we run this and maybe let's add a
print statement if we say something like
hello
server code go to console run the script
and we're going to see this is it
without hello being printed out now if
we use the Evo keyboard and wrap around
or die statement
save this
we're going to see Hello printed out
because the dial was handled and to
print out error we can use this special
variable with dollar sign at symbol if
we save this we run our code we're going
to see that we print hello and in this
variable we have the exception that was
drawn and also it indicates on which
line it was thrown in our script now
this is the old way let's see how we can
handle errors in new way so first of all
we need to use both for modules so let's
do that but the first module is called
try Thomas Mark Edge so use try colon
colon tiny
Hong Kong and smart catch
and the second module is called use
exception class
now let's start by handling exceptions
we try tiny smart catch what you can do
you can tap this keyword try followed by
sub and you can put your code in here in
between this try sub block now to catch
General errors we can use this catch
default followed by sub
and all the errors that are going to be
thrown which we do not handle in a
specific way are going to end up here
now for example if I say error that we
receive is in this local context denoted
by dollar sign underscore and here we
control for example
die this is it if we save this run our
code oops and looks like we forgot one
of the columns so exception common class
we rerun this and what we're going to
see is this is it which is exception to
the code on line 14. now this doesn't
seem really useful at this point I mean
we are throwing errors we're just
catching them by default so what's the
big deal with this now the real power
comes with using these in conjunction
with exception class now how you
construct custom exceptions with
exception class is by you provide a list
context and you define your new
exception for example my exception
and we can see this here in the
construct let's give an example so all
we need to do is we also need to wrap it
as a string your exception name has to
be a string now the question is how do
we use them well you use custom
exceptions by writing my exception or
however you named your exception and
calling a method which is going to be
inherited from the exception class
called Troll and here if you look at the
documentation you can throw exceptions
with specific messages so what we could
say is for example
ER
something is not right
now if we do this save the code we run
our script we're going to see something
is not right printed to the console okay
you might be wondering right we're
throwing custom exceptions now uh but
there's not much difference so I still
don't see the point of them but we have
to go back to the tritani smart catch
and explore the documentation there if
you look at the documentation you're
going to see that you can actually catch
specific exceptions so for example here
we can write something like catch when
exception name and the subroutine let's
do that after our try block and before
the catch default which is the Handler
or or on non-exceptions we can write
something like catch when and exception
name in this case this is my exception
or by zero annotation
which takes up routine and here we can
do something like say I know this
exception
exclamation mark
now if we set the code we run it and
here you can see that we actually
printed out I know this exception
instead of just following into the catch
default block now imagine in your code
you have different scenarios such as you
could not connect to the database or you
could not parse a Json where a file
system is full or so on and so on maybe
these are exceptions you want to recover
from in that case you can add as many
catchment blocks as you want for example
by exception and let's replace it with
something like app
file system
all
copy this exception
add it here
and let's quote it and now instead of
saying my exception throw we can do app
file system pull control
and we can say something like oh no the
disk space is full exclamation mark
let's introduce two scenarios for
example if you use a conditional
statement like if now I'm going to say
this random which we looked at before 5
is larger than 2 then we want to throw
this exception
else we want to draw
my exception
draw an error something else instead of
here we could actually print out
exceptions themselves
so I'm going to replace these maybe I'm
actually going to put them in a string
context
so we have a better visibility instead
of the full stack Trace so let's wrap
this context with string as well and if
we go to our terminal
run the code we're going to say
something else let's run it again
still something else oh I know our
exception changed because there's a
chance that if this random number is
larger than 2 we're gonna throw this
specific exception otherwise we're going
to throw the my exception so here the
first two times we threw the something
else and the third time we actually drew
the disk space exception that says the
disk space is full hopefully you do
agree that handling exceptions this way
is much much better approach and gives
you much more flexibility than just
simply putting die statements in your
code and trying to reject specific
exceptions we're not going to go into
too much detail on this however just now
that in our exception class we're not
just restricted to saying error
something we can also add our own
attributes that we can get on the
current context of a non-exception do
some additional logic but now what I'm
demonstrating here is that when you
throw specific custom exceptions you can
handle them in different ways in very
trivial approach that is just so much
better than throwing exceptions in the
default Broadway now this is a for this
video we looked at how we can do much
better exception handling using tritoni
smart catch and exception class modules
instead of the out of the box style
enable functions I hope you found this
video useful and I'll see you at the
next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will look at how we can
make web requests and parse responses
using Mojo user agent first of all why
are we using module user agent just to
clarify there are definitely other
modules in meta cpan ecosystem that
allows to make and parse web requests
however I find Mojo user agent to be
very user friendly and feature Rich and
this is what the modulations framework
is using behind the scenes there's
definitely a solid Choice once your user
agent includes some of great features
like parsing various content types for
example Json to hashf pending and
receiving data via websockets and
probably one of the most awesome
functions async requests using promises
if you come from JavaScript background
you might be very familiar of these
however if not in summary promises are
non-blocking async tasks you put in
background while running your code and
they will resolve so to say once the
task has been completed if it does not
make sense no worries we will look at
the basic example in a minute now as
before we you want to start you want to
go to meta cpan and you want to look for
Mojo cone colon user agent so if you
open this up as before the documentation
is quite good here and it gives you a
lot of nice examples of how you can run
them with promises in async even how to
use websockets and running multiple
requests in parallel but one step at a
time let's start by copying the module
name going to our terminal and
installing it so as before sleep and M
and the module name and we're going to
hit return and this is going to take a
minute or two and I'll see you back when
it's done installing now the module is
done installing and we're ready to
proceed running some web requests so
where do we go from here well as before
we want to start by using the module so
use Mojo
user agent and let's say our file now
let's go to our browser and what I'm
going to be using is this website called
Json placeholder type code so basically
what this website is it just kind of
gives you these mock responses in a Json
format and this is exactly what we want
to do we just want to test simple web
requests using get to fetch some posts
for example so I'm going to be using
posts and we can see that if we access
posts we're going to get 100 items and
we can also access specific posts before
slash one forward slash two and so on
let's copy this link which just accesses
the first post and let's go back to our
code now here I'm going to declare a
variable I'm going to say my post and
I'm going to set it as a string and here
I am just pasting in the link we just
copied from our browser now how do we
call this URL well we need an instance
of a user agent and as you know from
before you get instances from classes by
calling method new what we can do is we
can say my UA for user agent equals mojo
on colon user agent
arrow notation new and now we have
access to functionality of this module
on this instance now let's see how we
can make a get request if you go back to
documentation we're going to see that in
order to get data we need to call method
get followed by the URL and we also need
call result so let's try to do that if
we print something out from UA arrow
notation
get
followed by the link which is stored in
our post variable and then call result
which is a result semicolon got our
terminal Runner script referral
script.pl it looks like we actually need
this additional package to be installed
in order to run secure requests so since
you're calling https we need i o socket
SSL to be installed on our system so
let's run cpnm IO socket SSL
let's wait for this to finish installing
right and this is perfectly normal this
is actually great that we're getting
these errors because now we can look
together into how we can resolving these
dependencies now let's see if we can
install this module so if we do cpanem
Run net this is Lia wait for this to
finish installation and looks like it
failed again perfect I mean this happens
all the time and no need to be scared or
throw in the towel and give up so let's
look at the build log I'm going to print
this out what's in the build log it's
going to say I could not find lib SSL
headers and looks like we're actually
missing openssl required files in our
system in order to install this package
if you do get an error about not being
able to install that Els module and if
you're on Mac what you want to do you
want to run this command you can see in
the terminal which is Brew install open
SSL and that should take care of all of
the dependencies needed for that module
so I already have it installed and I
sent it to check if everything is
working and it is hopefully it's going
to be working for you as well however if
you are on a distribution like Ubuntu
what you want to do you want to run this
command which is sudo apt get install
lib SSL Dev alright so hopefully the
installation finished for you without
any issues let's try to run our script
again and I did not install the full
module yet we run the script and yes it
says that I O socket SSL is missing so
if you rerun the installation so cpnm
biosocket SSL run this let's wait a
minute and that should be fine and I'll
see you back once it's done alright so
the installation finished for movie
without an issues and hopefully it's the
same for you but if you are facing any
difficulties whatsoever please do leave
a comment and we can look into it
together right after all this hustle
let's go back to our scripts and let's
see if it's working now so Pro script.pl
if you run this what are we going to get
right so we see that this is actually an
instance of an object so here we're
printing out an instance of something
and something being message response now
now the question is what are we missing
to actually get the body of the response
well if we go back to the documentation
we can see here in quick Json API
requested basic authentication you don't
really need the authentication part but
from the example below we can see we're
calling results that we are doing in our
code as well but looks like we're not
actually calling Json method so it seems
that when you're calling results we're
getting back an instance of response and
there's also a method to request the
pause Json body so let's do that let's
call the result and arrow notation Json
said that try to call the mock IPA again
and we're going to get hash or this
looks better because this is actually no
hashref so that just means we want to
print this through dumper because if
you're just printing a hashref we're
going to get the reference in memory as
we saw before so that's why we need to
use the dumper first time the charm here
we go we got back a Json body which was
parsed into a hash ref and this looks
all good you can use other potentially
quite useful methods on the result
itself instead of just getting the body
directly for example I could save the
result into result equals here I get
post results and without calling Json
let's just say some stuff such as result
is success and also let's copy this line
and call this method code which is going
to give us the status code and let's
save that Rerun the request if only I
could spell success or missing 1s save
that Rerun the request and here we go we
can see that this request was successful
because we got a truthy value back and
here we can see the HTTP code for the
successful response which is 200 and
you're not just limited to get requests
you can use put requests or the post
requests you can submit form data or you
could submit Json data depends on your
use case which exactly type of requests
are you looking for and the examples
here are really great you can find a
blueprint for pretty much anything you
want to do with module user agents now
let's look at something more a little
bit Advanced talked about these promises
the beginning of the lecture I did
mention that promises allows us to make
many requests in parallel without
blocking the execution of our code let's
put that in a practice and see if it's
really true
now if we remove this print parts and
just simply try to get the same URL
couple of times let's say one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten so if
we do this we're going to reach out to
this URL and times in a sequential
manner right so this first request has
to succeed the second request has to
succeed third one and so on let's run
this and let's also remove the variable
names because we don't really need that
we don't want store results we just want
to reach out to these URLs and see how
long it takes to time something you can
use the system time command so let's use
that before Pro and run our script right
it took eight seconds for me to call 10
URLs for the Post one might be faster
for you might be longer depends on
connection but average for me is eight
seconds when it is not that great I
think that is quite true right the
question is how we can improve this so
if we go back to documentation which is
again pretty great when it comes to
showing examples you can see that there
is a comment saying concurrent
non-blocking requests synchronizer
promises well that looks promising so
let's keep in mind that we can call the
same methods as we did before we get but
we just need to end underscore e for
promise now let's go back to the code
let's replace this example
with something else I'm going to
construct couple of promises that we
want to resolve in asynchronous manner
in our code but what I'm going to do I'm
gonna declare a new array called
promises I'm going to call a map
function and I want to call this map
function from 1 to 10 elements basically
this is going to give us a new list for
one to ten items depending on what is
the return in the map function so in the
math function I'm going to do UA user
agent get underscore P for the promise
and here what I want to do I want to
copy the URL that we called before which
is the posts with number one I could of
course append a different post number
using the current context by source and
underscore but I'm not going to do that
because we did look at example using the
post id1 it's only fair that we use the
same IDs so now how we can actually get
results back from these promises you
need to use another module and this is
going to already be installed when you
install a module user agent it's one of
the dependencies and it's called mojo on
colon promise what this module takes is
a list of promises how you construct
this is mojo
promise
error notation all where you provide the
promises
and then you type then and in that then
function it expects a function so sub
this is just Anonymous subroutine
there's nothing really special about
this we're not assigning it to anything
we're just providing Anonymous
subroutine and what we can do here we
can get all the promises that have been
resolved in a list but we don't actually
need the parentheses since we are
accepting the list and we're going to
get this in the argument list and we
have seen this many times before and
this list is going to be populated by
this then method but the question is
what are we actually getting here in
this result we're going to be getting
back the response object exactly the
same as we did get from calling the get
link once so we had to call the result
and then we had to request decoder Json
body what we could do we could say
dumper
I want to say this for every single
result promise which is the response we
can use a loop which is four same as
with if conditionals we can use some of
the loops after the Declaration or for
code so here I'm going to say 4 result
and what I want to print out is the
current context which you're getting
from this Loop each item in result
as I mentioned this is the response but
it also contains other elements in this
result so I'm gonna access the first
item in the resolved list
the result
Json
and save this if you rerun our script
with time function
you're going to see that we have a
syntax error this is because we're
missing a semicolon after then block so
let's add a semicolon
we're on this and looks like nothing
happened this is because we are actually
missing another call after then change
function call if you look at the
documentation what you also need to do
we need to call the weight to obey our
promises which we are not doing let's
add this weight all as well let's chain
it after then
and rerun our script hey looks like it
took only four seconds from doing all of
these calls sequentially one by one so
we literally reduce the time to make
these requests by half which is amazing
so this is it for this video
we looked at how we can make web
requests using module user agent parse a
request response check the status codes
and do some very awesome things like
making multiple async requests using
promises I hope you found this video
useful and I will see you at the next
one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore how we can
write and read files in Pearl using out
of the box tools and we'll also look
into using Pro module called path tiny
which gives a nice and easy to use
interface to work with files however
let's start with looking into how we can
write and read files using Solutions
given by Pro now to write a file you can
use this open function and this open
function takes three things it's going
to take a variable which is going to be
a file handle and the next is going to
be a symbol that indicates if you want
to read a file or pen the file or
overwrite existing file content now here
what we can do we can try to write
something to a file to our current
location from where we're running the
script and I'm going to call it
test.text let's end this line with
semicolon now the first thing you
usually want to do you also want to call
the close statement on the file handle
but you don't want to end up having
multiple open file handles which can
lead to memory leaks it's a good
practice to always open and close your
file handles even if you want to move
them to different lines later on it's
just good to have it therefore
visibility and a reminder I'll turn this
line and now to actually write something
to the file we can use print
and instead of just printing something
like Hello World
to the standard output we can actually
provide a file handle and what's going
to happen instead of printing with the
standard outputs we're going to print to
this file handle which is going to write
something to our file if we save this
and run our script nothing happens but
that is good because we're also not
seeing any warnings however what we're
going to see that there's a new file
next door script and this file is called
test.text quite conveniently the file
also was created at a time of being
written to so we didn't have to take
care of that if we open this file we're
going to see Hello World now let's say
we want to write multiple lines what I'm
going to do I'm going to copy this print
statements couple of times save the file
run it again and if I go back to test
that text file I'm going to see multiple
lines printed to the file now what if we
actually had something in the file
already let's say I already exist and
saved in our text file go back to our
script
and we run it again and let's go back to
the file to the test.text what you're
going to see is that what we had
originally in our file was actually
overwritten and this is because when
we're using this greater than symbol
what's going to happen is the content of
that file is going to be overwritten we
did see many hello world lines but this
is also because we are working with a
single file handle so everything is
written to that one file handle which is
then saved to this file now that also
means that alternatively we would need
to read the file contents in reprint
them to the file and then append the
other lines we want to write to it but
there's an alternative what you can do
you can use these two great indent
symbols now if we save this and I'm
going to add new line character at the
end of our hello world lines and if we
go back to the test file and let's
reintroduce something like I already
exist if we save that go back to our
script rerun it and if we see or test
the text file now what happened we
actually preserved the original content
so that's the difference between 1
greater than and two greater than
symbols so if you're using one greater
than symbol it's going to override the
contents of the file however if you're
using two greater than symbols it's
going to append to the file and that's
exactly what happened here so we already
had a content and we just appended our
new Hello World lines now the question
is how we can actually read the content
of a file it's quite similar to writing
to file but we use less than symbol and
how we can store the content of the file
we can declare new variable for example
my content
equals and we haven't seen it before but
we can also use this do block and what
the do block allows you to do it allows
you to define the logic you want to
execute very similar to function but the
difference is that the block is actually
going to turn a value at the end so here
we want to return all the content that
we read in our file so how we can do
that is by saying local lower sign
forward slash and this line and then we
provide similar to taking an input what
we saw with the diamond operator instead
we can Define that we want to take the
input from this file handle which we
opened before on this line now if we
print out the content to say
content
save the file run the code again you're
going to see all the content printed
your console now let's quickly explore
what is going exactly here we have this
local dollar sign forward slash and file
handle to put it simply we are just
setting this real special variable to
undefine and we're setting it on the
find locally in this do block scope if
we wouldn't do that for example if I
remove local dollar sign forward slash
and rerun the code we're just going to
see the first one that we have in our
file which has already exists and hello
world that we can see here now the
reason why we want to localize this
variable and set it to undefined because
otherwise Pro is just going to read the
inputs up to the first break line it's
going to stop reading the file if we set
this special variable that indicates the
end of the line to undefined is going to
read all file you might be wondering
well why can't we just set this variable
to on the fund in general for example
before the code such as this variable
equals undefined and if you rerun this
it does work but the problem is that we
are affecting the scope of this variable
if we want to read different lines of
code or if we wanted to take input from
the terminal this means we have modified
this special end of the line indicator
because we're setting the scope globally
all we want to do by setting this
special variable to local in this do
block scope to be able to read contents
only of this file specifically without
modifying the special variable end of
the line indicator globally and this is
how all of this comes together here in
this do block we Define logic that we
want to execute in isolated scope in
this scope we'll localize the end of the
line variable to be undefined meaning we
want to read the full file content which
is currently held by this file handle
and we can do this by telling Pearl that
the end of the line separator should be
undefined meaning reading all the files
and also as I mentioned the difference
between if conditionals and the do block
is that the do block returns a value at
the end of the execution the meaning is
going to return all the content sense
that was read in from this input to put
it simply we're just doing this to be
able to read in the whole file through
this file handle we opened up on this
line just above the do block now there
is one Pitfall leading in Contents of a
small file is perfectly fine through
this approach however if you have files
that go into hundreds of megabytes or
even gigabytes do note what we're
actually doing we're reading the file in
the memory so this might not be the best
approach you want to take if you are
dealing with huge files what you
probably want to do you actually want to
read the file contents line by line and
in order to achieve that you can use the
while loop so let's replace this do
block with while
and what we're going to add in this
while loop expression is going to be
defined keyword and here what we're
going to do we're going to say my line
equals current line from the input of
the file handle now what we could do
then we could Define a new content
variable with an empty string and here
in a while block we could say that we
want to append to the content with DOT
equals the current line
and then we want to print out the
content if we save this rerun our code
we're going to see that the content
holds all the lines we read in and
appended to this content variable
alternatively you could instead print
line
and the current line we are iterating
over if we save this and remove the
content variable and we run the script
we're going to see that we read in each
line and we printed it out followed by
two new lines because the lines we have
in the file ends with new line and then
we're saying something which also adds a
new line and this is excellent approach
in case you want to parse the large
files one by line and honestly that's
probably the approach you want to take
most of the time instead of reading the
whole file in one go right so this is it
for this video we looked at how we can
read and write files in Pro using out of
the box solution we know how to write to
the files or pen to the files and read
the files however in the next lecture we
are going to explore alternative and
that alternative is using a module
called path tiny which gives you a very
nice interface to interact with all of
these actions where you want to write
three the pen to files and you don't
need to think about these internals of
localizing things and keeping of state
and so on because that's all managed by
the module I hope you found this video
useful and I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
the previous lecture we explored how we
can read and write files in Pro and
that's perfectly fine to use the out of
the box approach for trivial tasks read
or write to files however you might have
noticed that there is a lot of low-level
things you need to keep track on in
order to take the out of the box
solution when it comes to managing files
such as you need to create file handles
remember symbols for writing reading and
appending to files closing file handles
and so on it would be much better if you
could delegate these low-level tasks to
a module that can do repetitive steps
for us and it turns out there is such a
module well several but we will explore
one of the most popular ones called path
tiny pathani gives us an excellent and
easy to understand interface to do all
the actions we did before it's live fast
and in my humble opinion very user
friendly when it comes to working with
files now first things first in order to
use path tiny module we want to install
it and as before we can go to meta cpan
module repository and look for path All
In colon tiny if you open up the link as
before we're going to be met with great
documentation and it's going to give you
many examples to achieve exactly what
you're after even in the summary we can
already see some examples of how to read
and write to files and not just that we
can also read directories which is
pretty great so we'll start by
installing this module if you copy the
name of the module go back to the
terminal and as before run cpnm the
module name it's going to take a second
or two to get installed and I'll see you
back once this has finished now the
module has finished installing and we're
ready to use it in our code and in order
to use this module we can do the same
thing we have done before so we use the
use keyword path call colon tiny which
is this module's name and what this
module exposes is a method called path
and this path method takes a string
where you provide the file you want to
read or write to in this case I'm going
to provide a file which is called test
that text and I'm going to use the
relative directory you could use the
absolute directory to indicate where you
want to read or write the file from but
in my scenario I want to work with a
file which is relative from where I'm
running the script which is currently
Pearl underscore course folder and next
to the script.pl file and what this path
method returns is an instance of a class
that is going to have various methods
that is going to allow us to read and
write files so what we can do we can say
my
bath
and assign the return value to this path
variable and if you don't know from
where this plat function is coming from
I do encourage you to check the video
where we talk about the difference
between require and use keywords and how
some methods are automatically imported
by modules now returning back to our
example what we could do now we could do
path and color method spew
if you go back to the documentation
we're going to see that in order to
write files we can call this view method
that takes a list of data we want to
write
in this example we could provide a very
simple list for example three strings
that says a
B
and C if we save this file
run it
oops looks like we have syntax error and
yes seems like we're missing semicolon
at the end of this statement so if we
add a semicolon we run the file you're
going to see that there's a new file
that appeared next or script file which
is called test.txt and it contains three
things it contains ABC now here you can
see that we actually wrote separate
lines and you would be expecting that
it's going to write the Lines line by
line in the file but this is not the
case you do need to provide the
separator explicitly for example if I
replace this single quote characters
with double quote characters
and if we save this and also let's add
the new line at the end of each
character re-run the file
and let's see what's in the test file
now we're going to have a b and c on new
lines so do keep in mind that you do
need to provide new line separator when
you want to write your data on separate
lines now alternatively if we wanted to
read the file what we could do we can
use a method called slurp and how we do
that is by declaring a new variable
where we're going to store the content
of the file and I'm going to call it a
content
and assign the result of path slurp save
this we run the code and we probably
actually want to print out what's in our
content variable if I print out the
content set the file and we rerun the
script again we're going to see ABC
and this is the exact content that we
have in our file now alternatively you
could also use a method which is called
lines so instead of just reading
everything in in scalar context and just
having one string we can use lines that
we assigned to content which is an array
and here we can print out the dumper
backslash reference of the content just
to get a better representation of what's
in this array you can just turn it into
array ref so if you go to the console
and rerun the script file what we're
going to see is that we have each line
read separately and it ends with a new
line you could of course do some
processing you could remove the new line
but if you're happy to leave it as it is
then just now the lines do read the file
line by line by preserving the end
separator of that line now you can do
other very useful things with this
module and I do encourage you to check
the documentation there's an excellent
documentation of each of the methods you
can use to achieve things such as
modifying the permissions of a file or
moving a file from One path to another
this module also allows you to work with
directories and list files and
directories and so on but the end of the
day this module pretty much allows you
to do anything you would like to do with
files folders Reading Writing files
moving files modifying permissions
working with different paths so on and
so on now this is it for this video we
looked at an alternative of how we can
read and write files using a module
called pathani instead of using the pros
out of the box solution to work with
files I hope you found this video useful
and I'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in
this video we will explore how we can
run system commands through Pro there
can be some cases where you want to do
some sysadmin tasks that for example
requires you to list files run some
commands or maybe you want to create
your deployment scripts and you want to
execute some of the git commands so on
and so on as always scenarios depends on
the use cases now the good thing is that
Brill allows you to call system commands
and it actually allows you to call
system commands in three ways one way is
where you can actually capture the
outputs of the system command you run in
Pro script the second is that you can
run a system command without capturing
output and maybe you want to just
execute command and quit your script
afterwards so let's explore the first
scenario where we can run a system
command and capture the output of that
command you can invoke a system of
command by using two backticks for
example here I can say LS for list and I
want to list files in a current
directory what I could do I could say my
output equals the result of this command
if we run our script now if you also
print the outputs of photos stored in
this variable so say output
and run our Command we're going to see
script.pl so it listed and printed out
the files currently in our directory if
we did that in our terminal with ls and
the current directory we can see the
same thing now we can also make this a
little bit more useful and before
outputting the contents of the offer
directory what we could do we could say
run system command which is going to
create a file in our current directory
which are going to call based on this
context dot text file for each
list of numbers 1 to 10.
so this should create 10 files the names
from 1 to 10 and append text to it so if
we save this and we run our script
we're going to observe two things the 10
files were created in all current
working directory and also we got the
output from this list command I also
talked about Alternatives of how you can
run system commands if you might not
care about the output there's a keyword
you can use called system
so what system takes is a list of
commands you want to execute as strings
so for example we could say LS and the
second element is going to be the next
argument we want to run with the system
command and this would be equivalent of
running LS space dot forward slash if we
save this and let's actually try to
capture output of this and this equals
to our system command and if we print
this out by using say
output
and I'm also going to interpolate this
in a string which I'm going to add to
outputs save this go to the terminal run
the script what you're going to see is
that we actually get all the contents
printed out to the terminal but do take
note that these contents do not come
from the variable of output that we're
printing here what we're getting in the
output variable is actually 0 and 0
indicates a successful execution of this
system command now the system command
was actually running a child process the
contents of what we see here in our
terminal were printed out separately so
that is a key difference between using
backticks and using system command when
you do care about the outputs and saving
that to a variable you can use two
backticks and provide a command there if
you don't care about the output you can
use a function which is called system
and you provide all the arguments in a
list context now I also talked about the
Third Way which allows you to execute
commands and quit after execution so
let's try to do that and it's very
similar to system command what you do
you exec and let's still try to assign
outputs of this exact command and let's
try to print it out if I clear my
terminal I have the script file and
let's run our script again so
pearlscript.pl what we're going to
observe is a similar Behavior to the
system command we got the output printed
out from our child process and it's
still visible in our terminal however
we're not seeing anything printed out
after we run our exact command and that
is the key difference when you run exec
it's going to execute command and quit
the script so all the code you write
after that command is simply not going
to be taken in account so nothing is
printed to the terminal so you might be
wondering which command you would use
when again as always it depends on
scenarios you might want to list all the
files and parse the output from the
system command using the back text to
for example get all the file names you
might just care about running a system
command in background and continuing
your execution of the scripts without
caring about the output or alternatively
you might want to run some space
specific outputs in a use case where you
don't want to execute any follow-up code
if for example some conditional
statement was true it really depends and
it's always up to you which use case
you'll find the best fit for the job so
this is it for this video we looked at
three ways how we can run system
commands using backticks system keyword
and exact keyword I hope you found this
video useful and I'll see you at the
next one